SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY WILL COME TO ORDER YEAH
IN RESPONSE TO COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND A PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. THOSE OF US HERE ON THE
DOORS SEND SENATE STAFF WE ARE
LIMITING ESSENTIAL AND NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS. AND
ADHERING TO THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING AN ESSENTIAL HEARING
THAT'S THIS. AND HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. THE ONE WE ARE
PHYSICALLY AND THE MEMBERSARE
IN RIGHT NOW AND ONE OF THE
SECOND FLOOR. AND WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. BY
TELEPHONE THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IT IS
NOW. AND BY WILL ANNOUNCE THE
NUMBER NOW WHICH IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE
IS SIX TWO TWO SIX FIVE FIVE
EIGHT. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY BY
YOUR LINE NUMBER OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
THE WEIRD FEEDBACK NOISES YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR.
TO GIVING TESTIMONY ONCE YOU
ARE ABOUT TO BEGIN TESTIMONY
YOU ON MUTE. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU. OF COURSE
THOSE WHO ARE THE KEY WITNESSES
AND THE KEY WITNESSES. CAN I
SHARE A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES
I WILL SAY YOUR NAME AND YOU
WILL BE CALLING IN ON A
DIFFERENT LINE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE AS TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES. AS WE
ARE ADJUSTING AND YOUR
ADJUSTING TO THE- ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR- PATIENCE SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. SO WE ARE. WILL BEGIN
HEARING- FIRST SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA. SO WE HAVE- BY THE
AUTHOR. AND WE HAVE FOUR BILLS
ONE IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THE CONSENT BILL. RUMORS
THAT BUT ALSO THE VEHICLES THAT
ARE YEAR I JUST CAN'T READ
BECAUSE I HAVE NOT MY GLASSES
AUDIT SORRY SB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX BY SENATOR RUBIO IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE OTHER
BILLS EXCUSE ME SB EIGHT FIVE
THREE SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX AND
SB TWELVE TWENTY WILL BE HEARD-
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS I'M HERE ENTER HERE MORE
LAW. OR LACK BRADFORD. JACKSON
JACKSON HERE MITCHELL. MITCHELL
HERE MORALE WIENER FOR HER
RIGHT AWAY TO OUR OTHER MEMBERS
SHOW UP FOR AT BEFORE I ASK YOU
OFFER CONSENT CALENDAR MOTION
AND WE'LL JUST START WITH OUR
FIRST. AND THAT IS HER TARO S.
FIVE THREE CENTER HER. THE YEAH.
HERE'S A BETTER STORY APOLOGIES.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
EIGHT FIVE THREE A BILL
INTENDED TO EMPOWER AND
SAFEGUARD SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT. BUT THE CODEPENDENT
BECAUSE CLAIMED THE LIVES OF
MANY. DURING THIS SHELTER IN
PLACE MY SENATE DISTRICT HAS
SEEN A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
HOMICIDES SUICIDES AND OTHER
CRIMES. IN MY DISTRICT ARE
FRESNO COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
REPORTED A 77% INCREASE IN
REPORTS OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE INCLUDING ASSAULT
DURING THIS PERIOD. SB EIGHT
FIVE THREE AIMS TO ADDRESS THE
RISE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
DOMESTIC ASSAULT CASES BY
PROVIDING JUDGES HE
DISCRETIONARY TOOL TO EXTEND A
PROTECTIVE ORDER WERE BY
SURVIVORS CAN AVOID RELIEVING
THEIR TRAUMA. UNNECESSARILY
UNDER EXISTING LAW A PROTECTIVE
ORDER MAY BE VALID FOR UP TO
TEN YEARS WHEN THE PERPETRATOR
IS RELEASED HOWEVER AFTER THIS
TEN YEARS A CRIMINAL COURT NO
LONGER HAS JURISDICTION FOR A
SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT SEEK
AN EXTENSION. THE SURVIVOR MUST
RETURN TO CIVIL COURT AND
REQUEST A HEARING WHICH
EFFECTIVELY MEANS RELIEVING THE
TRAUMA. MY WHAT IS TODAY. A CAN
EXPLAINS WITH A INSTANCE WHERE
TRYING TO ADDRESS WITH ME TODAY
IS TO MORE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FOR CLARK COUNTY. AND A REMAND
DOES THIS RIVER SEXUAL SOUGHT
FOR MY DISTRICT. SO FOR OUR KEY
WITNESSES I INDICATED. YOU HAVE
A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES AND
WE'LL START WITH TIM WARD. THE
DA FROM TULARE COUNTY FOLLOWED
BY IRENE MENDEZ GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU TIME
TO LARRY COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CAN WARD YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY PROTECT SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AS WELL AS
PARENTS HAVE MOLESTED OR
EXPLOITED CHILDREN. A
FUNDAMENTAL ASPECT IS SURVIVING
TRAUMA IS A BASIC PEACE OF MIND
THAT COMES FROM KNOWING YOUR
ABUSER WILL NOT ATTEMPT TO HAVE
ON WANTED CONTACT WITH YOU. I
SAY ON WANTED BECAUSE THIS BILL
IS PREDICATED UPON THE VICTIMS
CONSENT THIS LAW WOULD ALLOW
THAT CHOICE TO REST WITH THE
VICTIMS AND NOT JUST WITH THE
OFFENDER. PLEASE STAND WITH
pTHAT VOICE AT ITS CORE THIS IS
ABOUT GIVING FULL AND FREE
ACCESS TO THE COURTS OR
PROTECTIVE ORDER MAY ATTACH
CONCURRENT THE DURATION OF THE
FENDER SEX REGISTRATION. IN
TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT OF CO
RECORD OPERATIONS THE ABILITY
TO ACCESS HEARINGS IS LIMITED
AND OR HOUSE CAN BE
INTIMIDATING BARRIERS
ESPECIALLY FOR SOME MEMBERS OF
OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WHETHER IT'S- ALL PHILIP
CONSTRUCT EVEN UPPER STATE. A
NUMBER OF THIRST CAN KEEP PACE
FROM POTENTIAL IN SO COURT. A
PLEASE DON'T FORGET THE PAIN
PART OF PROCESS FOR ANY
SURVIVOR WHICH THE ULTIMATE
REALITY TO SHE MUST. CORRECT
PERCENT. UNNECESSARY DOUBLED I
WOULD AND FOR. YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TODAY TO ONE WORD. THAT
IS THE REASON IS GOING TO HAVE
ANY TIME YOU'LL HAVE TO. WRAP
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY TO JUDAH
JUST AND AUTUMN. THERE'S DO
PROCESS AND WITH RECENT. IN
SECOND REGISTRATION ACT THIS
BILL IS. IT'S A- AND I ASK YOU
TO STAY WITH SOME. AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MORNING I AM I RE
MENDOZA I LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK SENATE
BILL. EIGHT THREE. HUNDRED
CAMBERED HE AND TWO I LOVE UP
IN MY TO THE SELLING OF PAIN OR
THE MAIL WAS ON TOP OF ME AND
ME. I THEM ALL OF ME AND TO THE
BACK. THEN I HEARD FRONT DOOR
SLAM I TO WINDOW AND THE WHEN
SCREEN HAD BEEN REMAIN AND THE
WAS. AFTER NUMBER. WOULD COME
CHART WORK BY ANY COME HIM OF
RAPE. HE WAS INTO THE AND INTO
THE EIGHTEEN I BEGAN BE HER AND
IN AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA BY
FAMILY. I CONTACTED THE GIRL
AGENT AND HE WERE TO HELP ME I
CONTACTED THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S AND WAS TOLD I KNOW
LAW HAD A- OR- I FEEL THAT
PROTECTIVE MAYBE JUST PIECE OF
PAPER BUT IT THE STATE. A
PERFECT ORDER GIVE ME AB OF
MINE I DON'T FEEL LIKE I HAVE
TO WATCH MY BACK AND I'M NOT
ALONE. I'M AFRAID JUST. GETTING
FOR PROTECTIVE ORDER FOR SEXUAL
STILL PROVIDE FOR IT I CAN'T
EMPOWER OTHERS TO SPEAK OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BEFORE I
OPEN THE- PHONE LINES TO THE
OTHER PUBLIC IN SUPPORT I
FORGOT TO ASK YOU MISTER TODD
OR YOU TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
RECOMMENDED THAT NOT TODAY
MADAM CHAIR SORT NOT TODAY
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. SERVE
THE YOU WILL NOT BE TAKING THE
MOMENT THAT IS CORRECT. A LOT-
A MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINE. FOR SUPPORT. I AM
ON THE PHONE NINE FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO ONCE
AGAIN ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AND
THOSE OF YOU IN SOME FOR YOU
CAN GIVE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND JUST SAY SUPPORT. THAT'S
ALL THAT'S. THAT'S THE ONLY
TIME YOU'LL BE GIVEN. AND I'M
SHOWING EIGHT. OKAY PLEASE
PROCEED. NINE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIFTY FOUR
ONCE AGAIN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BLIND FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE RESPOND. WILL
CONTINUE ON. FIND FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JONATHON FELDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION OR. LINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND A KELLY
ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY AMALI
IN SUPPORT. BLIND FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TIFFANY
MATTHEWS ON BEHALF BY
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND THE COURT. LINE
SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
RIGHT NOW. GOOD MORNING TO MORE
TOOK OUT ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
AND NINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NUMBER KIND OF AN AYE
OPPOSED MONTEL GINA. THANK YOU
KNOW MORE LINES AT THIS TIME.
I'D LIKE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER. CALLERS IN SUPPORTING
MAY NOT HAVE CALLED IN YET FOR
MAY NOT HAVE PUSHED THE-
APPROPRIATE BUTTON FOR SB EIGHT
FIVE THREE MODERATOR PLEASE
INDICATE WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
IN ORDER TO. TESTIFY THAT'S FOR
ONE OF THE CANDLES AND SUPPORT
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
ONCE AGAIN BILLS AND SUPPORT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
I'M SHOWING NO LINES AT THIS
TIME. ALRIGHT SO WE WILL MOVE
THEN TO OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
TO KEY. OPPONENTS MY COULD
DOCTOR OFF FROM A SEAL YOU. AND-LESLIE R. CALDWELL HOUSTON FROM
THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS YOU
AVERAGE A SHARED THREE MINUTES-
MY QUE YOU MAY GO FIRST LESLIE
FOLLOWED GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
DR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE IF YOU
KNOW YOUR CALIFORNIA. WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENTION AND PROTECTING
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE WE
ARE REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE EIGHT TRIED THREE. FIRST
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY CURRENT LAW ALREADY
ALLOWS COURT TO RESTRAIN PENAL
CODE TO NINETY REGISTRANTS FROM
CONTACT WITH VICTOR AND IN A
VARIETY OF SCENARIOS FOR
VARYING LENGTHS OF TIME. WELL
WE ARE GENERALLY WARY OF
RESTRAINT ON INDIVIDUALS
LIBERTY BASED ON PREDICTIONS
THAT A PERSON WILL COMMIT CRIME
IN THE FUTURE WE BELIEVE
CURRENT LAW WHICH SETS CLEAR
UPPER LIMIT FOR THESE
RESTRAINTS AND INVOLVED PROCESS
SPEAKER ON GOING REVIEW BASED
ON NEED. STRICTER MORE.
APPROPRIATE BALANCE. SECOND WE
ARE CAN THAT THIS BILL MAY ACT
HAVE ON IN. CONSEQUENCE OF
HINDERING. FROM TECH FAST
REHABILITATION AND RE ENTRY
INTO PROPRIETY PEOPLE REQUIRED
TO REGISTER AS A SEX OFFENDER
ALREADY FACE DIFFICULTY FINDING
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
REUNITING WITH THEIR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES AND
PARTICIPATING IN DAILY LIFE.
THE RESTRICTING A PERSON'S
MOVEMENTS WILL ONLY CAUSE
GREATER DESTABILIZATION AND
COULD ULTIMATELY INCREASE A
PERSON'S LIKE 3100% OF THE TIME
AND LASTLY WE FEAR THAT PLACING
A PERSON UNDER COURT ORDER
POTENTIALLY FOR THE REMAINDER
OF THEIR NATURAL LIVES. LONG
AFTER COR AND LOST YOUR
INSPECTION OVER A CRIMINAL CASE
AND WITHOUT AN ONGOING SHOWING
NEED PROTECTION ORDER. THIS
CONSTITUTES CONCERNS FOR THESE
REASONS WHERE EXACTLY OPPOSED
TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND-
MISS HOUSTON. YOU MAY BEGIN
MISS CALDWELL HOUSTON. GOOD
MORNING THIS NEGLECT LIKE
CARDWELL HOUSTON FOR CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
WELL WE WELCOME THE AMENDMENT-
WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED DUE TO THE
LACK OF JUDICIAL REVIEW
RESTRAINING ORDERS ARE BACK.
THANK YOU AND WHEN A REQUIRED
REGISTRY AND THERE WOULD BE NO
HEARING TO DETERMINE WHETHER A
RESTRAINING ORDER IN THE
PROGRAM. THE BILL IS AND CUT.
THE BILL IS NOT EVIDENCE BASED
NOT EVIDENCE INFORMED THE DATA
WE HAVE JUST YOU REGISTER AND
THREE AT THE END. THERE IS A
FAIR REMEDY AND GLOBAL COURT.
SHOULD THE VICTIM NEED TO RENEW
AND EXTEND AFTER THE TEN OR
TWENTY YEAR PERIOD. WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR NOTEBOOK. THANK
YOU NOW- NOW THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE KEY WITNESSES WE CAN
OPEN THE PUBLIC LINES IN MY
APOLOGIES I NEED TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE SECOND.
FLOOR ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE THAT
I SEE IN THIS ROOM TO TESTIFY
ON THIS BILL I FORGOT TO ASK
ABOUT THE SECOND FOR HEARING
ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
SECOND FLOOR HEARING ROOM. SO
WE CAN PROCEED NOW TO THE PHONE
LINES. AND APOLOGIES FOR NOT
HAVING ACKNOWLEDGED THE TO
FISCAL ROOMS FIRST- GO AHEAD
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. YOU AND THE MODERATOR
WILL INDICATE TO YOU WHAT TO DO
AND YOU WOULD THEN CAN GIVE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
INDICATE YOUR POSITION GO AHEAD
MODERATOR ONCE AGAIN. IF YOU
ARE OPPOSE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. IF YOU ARE TO RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU ARE FINE
SO AGAIN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO TO RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER IF YOU ARE OPPOSED. AND
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE SEVERAL
QUEUING UP. AND I'M SHOWING
ROUGHLY TWENTY. ONCE AGAIN ONE
AND THEN ZERO. REALLY OKAY WITH
YOU. SO THERE'S NO ONE ON A
NOTE BUT GO AHEAD MODERATOR.
AND IF YOU'RE READY FOR
RESPONSES. THIS WILL GO FIRST
TO LINE OF LYING THIRTY EIGHT.
YOUR LINE IS ARGUABLY YOUR
MORNING THIS IS GREGORY FELL ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB.
UNDERSELL THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE FIFTY FOUR. TENNECO READ
OUR MOM BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE RESPECTFULLY AND WITH
EACH YEAR CARE AND CONCERN FOR
VICTIMS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU VOCAL CAROLINE EIGHT.
BALUCHI ALLIANCE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL SEX OFFENSE LAWS
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX.
ROGER HONEYCUTT BUSINESSMAN
FROM MODESTO I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY FOUR MY
NAME IS ROBERTA SHORTS AND I'M
A VICTIM OF CHILD MOLESTATION
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY SEVEN. LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE WILL CONTINUE LINE FORTY SIX.
LINE FORTY SIX. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NINE FORTY SIX. WE WILL
CONTINUE LINE SIXTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS THE TIME IS
ALSO WITH INITIATE JUSTICE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
CAN'T GARNER OUR RETIRED
CALIFORNIA IN SAN DIEGO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU LINE FORTY NINE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE BILL CALLS.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING. THE. ONE
OUT OF TEN DOT EVERY OTHER.
THROUGH MODERATOR PLEASE
CONTINUE. IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION WHO ARE
CALLING IN THE PUBLIC LINE. CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL IN. THE CALL
FROM SAN THROUGH THIS HAPPENS
OUT THERE OKAY SO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SB EIGHT
FIVE THREE WHO CALLED IN YOU
NEED TO CALL AGAIN NOPE OKAY HE
HAS TO RE ESTABLISH OKAY POLICY
OKAY. PAUL JEEZ IT'S A WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES BUT THEY WILL BE
RESOLVED AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO
HEAR TESTIMONY IN JUST A MINUTE
MODERATOR SOON AS YOU HAVE. THE
CONNECTION BACK WOULD YOU
PLEASE- ALLOW THOSE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION WE PLEASE
RECOGNIZE THEM SO WE CAN
CONTINUE.
THREE OF THE EIGHTEEN
T. LINE ESTABLISHED AGAIN.
WHAT'S HAPPENING. THE OTHER
FALLING BACK IN. THEY'RE
FALLING BACK RIGHT NOW JUST BE
A MOMENT WHEN IT WILL HAPPEN
SOON OTHER WORDS THEY DID HAVE
TO CALL BACK IN NO NOT THE
CALLERS JUST. RECALL MY- HE THE
RUNS OUT OF THE CITY. NOTHING
HAPPENED CALLER STAY ON THE
LINE EIGHTEEN T. WILL GET TO
YOU SOON.
WHAT THE LINE.
AND
WE'RE STILL WAITING EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN. CURRENTLY MY
LISTED OKAY MICHAEL JACKSON.
YEAH IT T. MODERATE ARE YOU
THERE. DIAL BACKING DOWN THE
LINE AND CONNECT BACK TO THE.
THE EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR CAN.
YEAH THANK. PFIZER EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
JUST INSTRUCT THOSE CALLERS WE
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM YET WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO AND THEN WILL
YOU PLEASE JUST PROCEED AND
ALLOW THE FIRST LINE. TO
TESTIFY. AND ONCE AGAIN IF WE
HAVE NOT HEARD FROM YOU PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE. LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. EUGENE DARDEN
FROM SAN DIEGO AND I'LL QUOTE.
BLIND FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE WILL CONTINUE THANK YOU I
AND THIRTY SEVEN POINT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ON MUTE. NINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AB GARDENA FROM CHINO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. NINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE WILL CONTINUE LINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MARK FORTY NINE. PLEASE SPEAK
LOW YES GO AHEAD WE CAN HEAR
YOU. MY NAME IS STEP AND CAROL
FROM THE CITY OF MARIETTA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. FIND TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE LET THEM SEE
FROM STANISLAUS COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. IN MY NAME IS
CANDY MC FROM STANISLAUS COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE WILL CONTINUE. NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONCE AGAIN NINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL CONTINUE
LINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT'S A LOT ABOUT A KIND
OF AN ABSOLUTE YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS AC CHOP FROM
THE ALLIANCE FOR CONSTITUTION.
LAW I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB
A TACTIC. THANK YOU LINE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS ANNA TO REGAIN FROM SAN
MATTEO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE DISPEL. THANK YOU LINE
SEVENT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LARA LEGAL CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU LINE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS JAMIE DEVOID OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU LINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL
CONTINUE NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SHINING STAR
MILLER I'M SOMETIMES IN BEACH
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU LINE
AT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU LINE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS KERRY POSEY
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. EARLY WE HAVE. ONE MORE
PERSON. ONE MOMENT. AND THAT'S
ONE ZERO TO GIVE YOUR NAME TO
THE OPERATOR. WE'LL GO TO. LINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL WE CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL CONTINUE LINE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS JOE SILENTLY FROM LOMPOC
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU NINE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NECESSARY RUMBLES
FROM SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JAMES CAAN
FROM LOS ANGELES I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
SHOWING NO MORE RESPONSIVE
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALRIGHT LET ME
JUST BECAUSE OF THE TECHNICAL
ISSUES LET ME JUST SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTED
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT FIVE THREE. YOU MAY CALL.
IN IF YOU WERE YOU HAD BEEN
DISCONNECTED PREVIOUSLY- THE
PHONE LINE IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX TWO TWO SIX
FIVE FIVE EIGHT IT'S ALSO ON
THE SCREEN LOTUS WAIT ABOUT
THIRTY SECONDS TO SEE IF
THERE'S- ANYONE WHO GOT CAUGHT
UP IN THE- TECHNICAL ISSUES.
BEFORE WE OPEN UP THE DíAS.
AND IF YOU DID NOT GET A CHANCE
TO RESPOND AS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE A RESPONSE FROM
LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BLIND TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE
CONTINUE. OKAY MY WHAT. HOW WAS
CALIFORNIA AND I. YEAH THANK
YOU. MODERATOR THERE ANY OTHER
LINES. AND LINE. ONE MOMENT
LINE EIGHTY TWO IF YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
THIS FRIDAY LATE FROM SUNNYVALE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. AND ONE MORE
PERSON IS CAN WE KNOW IT'LL BE
TESTAMENT. ANYONE ELSE IF YOU
DID NOT RESPOND ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND IT LOOKS LIKE THAT
RESPONSE. COME FROM BLIND
EIGHTY FOUR LINE EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS DAVID HERE ON A
RESIDENT OF EL DORADO COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND I'M SHOWING
NO MORE RESPONSIVE TO PLEASE
CONTINUE. AND I'M SORRY ONE
PERSON JUST CUED UP IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. ALL OTHER DATES
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ANOTHER
PERSON IS CUED UP SO TO BE
TESTAMENT. IN. WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AT SACRAMENTO AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU. AND
LINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS WARNER
CARPENTER FROM SANTA CLARITA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. AND I'M SHOWING NOR
THE RESPONSES AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT- IT CLEARLY IF THERE WAS
ANYONE WHO IN SOME OF US IN%
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WHO DIDN'T
GET THEIR OPPORTUNITY- BUT YOU
HAVE NO OTHER CALLERS ON THE
LINE MODERATOR. NO OTHER
CALLERS SAID OR ALIENATING I'M
SO I KNOW WHAT THE RESPONSE IS
AT THIS TIME OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
NOW WE WILL- OPEN IT TO DISCUSS
OR COMMENT ON THE DíAS.
MEMBERS SIX OF THE CENTER MORAL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. WHEN I
SERVICE SUPERVISOR FOR THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CAME IN WITH THE
AGENDA ITEM WHERE HE WANTED TO.
PROHIBIT ANYONE ON THE. SEX
OFFENDER LIST TO NOT BE ABLE TO
GO TO OUR PUBLIC PARKS AND- IT
JUST SEEMED LIKE A RIGHT JUST
BILL OF COURSE YOU WOULDN'T
WANT SOMEONE ON THE SEX
OFFENDER LIST TO GO TO. PARKS
WHERE THERE'S- SMALL CHILDREN
IN. AND ABOVE IT BUT READING
THE BILL ARE THE BILL THE
AGENDA ITEM WE WOULD CALL IT IS
SUPERVISOR. THERE WERE SOME
REAL CONCERNS ABOUT
CONSTITUTIONAL. RIGHTS AND THE
REST AND SO I WAS VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE. WITH THE BILL
BUT HOW DO YOU OF OUR THE
AGENDA ITEM BUT HOW DO YOU VOTE
NO ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS. SO I
VOTED FOR IT ONLY TO HAVE. L.
HAVEN'T RULED IN COURT THAT IT
WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL. SO MY
SUSPICIONS WERE CONFIRMED BUT-
IT GOT ME ON A ON A JOURNEY- ON
THIS A SEX OFFENDER LIST OR THE
REGISTRATION ACT. IN NOT ALL.
INDIVIDUALS ON THIS LIST ARE
GUILTY OF RAPE THEY COULD'VE
BEEN URINATING OUTSIDE IF YOU
HAD NO. CONTACT PHYSICAL
CONTACT WHATSOEVER. AND SO
THERE BUT THERE WAS NO DE
GRADATION. SO I BELIEVE IT WAS
SENATOR WINNER THAT DID IT THE
BILL THAT SAID LET'S HAVE SOME
GRADATION AND I. I SUPPORTED
THAT BILL IN. AND I KNOW IT'S
TAKING. DEPARTMENT JUST A LONG
TIME TO GET EVERYONE CATEGORIZE
BECAUSE THAT'S YOU KNOW
MANPOWER MANAGEMENT- CONCERNED
WITH. SO I ET YOU SEE THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING GOING ON
MADAM CHAIR WOULD YOU TAKE A
LITTLE DEEPER INTO THIS TYPE OF.
LEGISLATION YOU COULD TELL BY
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
CALLED IN OPPOSITION. SO I'M
I'M JUST HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ONE I APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY.
OF A MISS MENDEZ BECAUSE I
WANTED TO GET THE CONTEXT THAT
WAS NOT IN MY- PORTS SO I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN BUT I
ALSO HAVE THIS CONCERN WERE
WITH THE PARK SITUATION YOU
KNOW. EITHER YOU CAN TAKE YOUR
KIDS TO THE PARK WEHAD ONE.
WITNESS AT ONE BILL THAT-
ACTUALLY SAID OUR ARMED I WAS
THE CITIZEN OF THE YEAR. IN MY
TOWN I'M A GOOD GUY I MADE A
MISTAKE SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY
BUT- YOU KNOW- WHY WHY SHOULD I
BE PROHIBITED FROM TAKING MY
KIDS TO THE- TO THE PART. TIME
I'M JUST KIND OF LOOKING FOR
BALANCE AS OPPOSED TO A SCARLET
LETTER- AND I'M I'VE BEEN
READING THE BILL AND I I'M NOT
ALL AND BEING TOLD THAT IF YOU
COMMIT A FELONY OFFENSE
REQUIRING THAT YOU BE PUT ON
THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRATION.
LIST THEN YOU COULD HAVE HAVE
HAVE THIS EXTENDED FROM TEN
YEARS TO MAYBE EVEN A LIFETIME.
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS. ABOUT THE
DETAILS ALL I COULD FIND WAS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THAT ENTAILS BUT- IS
THAT GOING TO BE A LIFE
SENTENCE FOR A- FATHER OR
MOTHER AND- HOW DOES THAT.
IMPACT THE RAISING OF THE KIDS
OR INVOLVEMENT WITH THE KIDS.
AND THEN IT DOES LOOK A MENTION
LOT ABOUT GUN OWNERSHIP WHICH I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE AND WANT
TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM HAVING GUNS
AND THEY CAN'T CONTROL THEIR
TEMPERS. SOLD THIRD TRY TO CAN
YOU CAN YOU HELP ME OUT A
LITTLE BIT JUST TO TRY TO FIND
THE BALANCE IN IN IT IS A TOO
BRODEUR'S IT MORE SPECIFIC I'M
JUST NOT GETTING IT. SAID THE
BILL EIGHTEEN YOU MAY. RESPOND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WILL A
TWO MORE TO STILL ON THE LINE I
WILL DEFER TO HIM ARE. YES GOOD
MORNING THIS IS- DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WARD MAY I- RESPOND
TO- THE SENATORS- COMMENTS
THERE YES BRIEFLY AND
SPECIFICALLY. THANK YOU HI I
THINK IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT-
THIS BILL WILL TAKE EFFECT
UPON- THE CHANGES THAT. SENATOR
WINNERS BILL DID- THAT CHANGED
AND REALLY REFORMED AND
MODIFIED THE THREE TIER SEX
REGISTRATION I TO THOUGHT THAT
WAS A WELL MEASURE DEAL A
CURRENT LAW DOES ALLOW. VICTIMS
TO HAVE A PROTECTIVE ORDER UP
TO TEN YEARS VIA THE CRIMINAL
COURT- THE CRIMINAL COURT CASE-
YOU DO- SENATOR YOU ARE CORRECT
AND- THE CURRENT LAW DOES ALLOW
AND CERTAIN FAMILY LAW
SITUATIONS FOR. A LIFETIME
RESTRAINING ORDER OF THE OF THE
FAMILY COURT SO THE CONCEPT OF
A RESTRAINING ORDER FOR THAT
DURATION IS NOT IN AND OF
ITSELF AND CONSTITUTIONAL- I
WOULD FOCUS ON REALLY TWO
ASPECTS ONE REALIZING THAT THE-
YEAR TWO AND YEAR THREE
OFFENDERS- DO REPRESENT THE
MOST SERIOUS AND VIOLENT. MAYBE
A BIT YOU'LL- OFFENDERS AND
ALSO WHAT THIS BILL DOES DOES
NOT- REALLY ADD TO THE EFFECT-
HAVING THE ABILITY TO GO AND
HAVE A RELEASE VIA THE CRIMINAL
COURT A VICTIM CAN GO TO THE
CIVIL COURTS AND GET A
RESTRAINING ORDER. THAT'S A
BALLOT FOR FIVE YEARS AND EVERY
FIVE YEARS COME BACK TO COURT
AND HAVE THAT READ- RE OPT OR
RENEWED IF YOU WILL SO AGAIN
THE PATIENT. IS OTHER UNDER.
BILL DE INCLUDE TO PASS BECAUSE-
ALL A- HEARING THE QUEUE WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO A COUNCIL RIGHT
TO COUNSEL AND THE HEARING IS
NO COST TO HIM OR HER. JUST AS
IT WOULD BE NO COST TO THE
VICTIM SO IN A WAY CENTER WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS KIND OF MOVING
THE MECHANISM. OF IN A WAY A
RIGHT THAT A VICTIM ALREADY HAS
A FROM A CIVIL PROCEEDING TO A
CRIMINAL HEATING AND ALL IN
WITH THIS. THE BURDEN OF PROOF
IN A CRIMINAL PROCEEDING- IS
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT WITH
FOREIGN ABOVE THAT IS WHAT THE
REQUIRED FOR A SCHOOL
PROCEEDING- IN THIS CASE.
COMMITTEE EVIDENCE. THANK YOU
SO THAT YOU ARE SAYING THAT. TO
IN TWO OR THREE OFFENDERS. IS
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD APPLY TO.
YES BUT IT GOES BY THE FIVE
DESCRIBED THE CURRENT LAW.
PROVIDE A FIVE C. DESCRIBED IF
THE CURRENT LAW PROVIDES THE
TEN YEARS AND IN INCREMENTS OF
ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS SO IN.
THIS BILL IS YOU DESCRIBED.
WHAT HE DESCRIBED YES THIS BILL
AS WRITTEN WOULD COVER TIER TWO
AND THREE. BUT IN FACT THE. THE
RESTRAINING ORDER THAT WOULD BE
TIED TO THE PAROLE WOULD BE
LIFETIME. AND SO THE MANAGER
WILL IF I MAY ASK THE QUESTION
WHAT WHAT AM I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE THE AMENDMENTS SEARCH
PROPOSE BUT WHAT A MALE
ANTHOLOGIES SO WHAT. BECAUSE
AS- YOU POINTED OUT CENTER MORE
LOCK. BE A THOSE WHO COMMIT A
SEX OFFENSE. THE SEX OFFENSES
ARE NOT ALL EQUAL AND- AS WE
ADJUSTED IN ADJUSTING THEIR
REGISTRY SENATOR WINNERS BILL
WE RECOGNIZED THAT OUR PREVIOUS
APPROACH TO THE REGISTRY WAS A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL IN WAS
INAPPROPRIATE AND SO WE CREATED
A THREE TIERS AND THE FIRST
YEAR PUT YOU ON A REGISTRY FOR-
AND CORRECT ME CENTER WHEN FROM
WRONG BUT FOR TEN YEARS THE
SECOND TIER. TWENTY YEARS IN
THE THIRTY YEARS BASICALLY
PERMANENT. AND SO. IN
UNDERSTANDING THE DA OBVIOUSLY.
HAS IN MIND SOMETHING BROADER
BUT IN UNDERSTANDING FROM A
VICTIM PERSPECTIVE WHAT. ONE
GOAL OF WHAT WAS TRYING TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THIS LAW WAS
TO PER TO PROTECT THE VICTIM
AND NOT PUT A VICTIM IN THE
SITUATION WHERE THE VICTIM HAS
TO GO BACK TO CIVIL COURT TO
GET TO CONTINUE AGAIN AND AGAIN
TO GET A RESTRAINING ORDER IN
THOSE CASES OF. BE THE THIRD
TIER TYPE OF SEX OFFENSE AND SO
WHAT THE COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED
IS THAT THE BILL BE AMENDED SO
THAT THIS PERTAINS TO EVERYONE
WHO FALLS IN THE TIER THREE AND
EFFECTIVE RONA FALLS IN THE
TIER THREE. THERE'S A LITTLE
VARIATION BUT BASICALLY- DANTE
SOURCE NECK NERO'S THE CATEGORY
OF OFFENSES AND NOW THERE ARE
SOME WHO BELIEVE EVEN OUR
AMENDMENT WOULD STILL BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE OF A
POTENTIAL LACK OF JUDICIAL
REVIEW. THAT DO DAY AGAIN
THAT'S REALLY FOR THE COURTS TO
DETERMINE- OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
STAFF WOULDN'T HAVE DRAFTED
SOMETHING THAT THEY WERE
COMPLETELY CLEAR WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IF YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY THEY
WERE THEY WERE TRYING TO FOLLOW
THE- THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IS ALLOWABLE AND TO
PROVIDE AN AMENDMENT THAT NEAR
ROAD AND YET STILL GAVE THOSE
VICTIMS. OF THOSE OUR WHAT WE
CALL LIFE TIME FELONY SEXUAL
OFFENSES THE TYPE THAT YOU GET
A LIFE SENTENCE NO LIFE
SENTENCE DOESN'T MEAN YOU SPEND
YOUR ENTIRE LIFE IN PRISON. IT
JUST MEANS THAT BEFORE YOU
WOULD EVEN BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PAROLE YOU WOULD ALREADY HAVE
BEEN IN PRISON FOR A GOOD
NUMBER OF YEARS USUALLY MINIMUM
OF TWENTY. BUT THEN IF YOU ARE
SUCCESSFUL ON PAROLE AND IF WE
LOOK AT THE HISTORY. IT'S IS
THAT YOUR ABILITY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING PROLES
PRETTY LOW. BUT LET'S SAY YOU
ARE THAT AT THAT POINT. THE
TECH ALMOST PERMANENT
RESTRAINING ORDER WOULD BE PUT
ON YOU. RATHER THAN THE FACT
I'M HAVING TO GO BACK TO COURT
IN REQUESTING. SO THAT IS WHAT
WE WERE TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH
THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MANAGER AND A- CONSULTANT-
PLEASE CORRECT A FIVE IF THERE
WERE A I AM NOT A LAWYER HERE
SENATOR WIENER IS A LAWYER
SENATOR JACKSON'S LAWYER MY
CONSULTANTS LAWYERS SO OF
COURSE ICE I DESCRIBE THESE
THINGS IN. COMMON VERNACULAR
AND SOMETIMES CAN MAKE A- SO GO
AHEAD CONSULTANT THERE'S A
SUPER CERTAIN GROUP OF SEX
OFFENDERS THAT HAVE LIFETIME
PAROLE SO THIS WOULD THE
AMENDMENT WOULD STRIKE UP THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE BAT IN
THE BILL AND INSTEAD. CHOIR IN
THE CASES WHERE THE SEX
OFFENDER AS LIFETIME PAROLE FOR
THE PAROLE BOARD TO PUT THE
RESTRAINING ORDER AS A
CONDITION OF PAROLE. SO THERE'S
WE'VE ALREADY SELECTED THE
WORST OF THE WORST AND GIVEN
THEM LIFETIME PAROLE. NO ONE
NIGHT IN DESCRIBING NOW I. AS A
PERSON WHO IS A- EXPERIENCE
SEXUAL CRIME- AS THE VICTIM YOU
DON'T EVER WANT TO MOST PEOPLE
WE NEVER WANT TO EVER DO WITH
THE PERPETRATOR AGAIN WE NEVER
WANT TO HAVE TO GO TO COURT WE
NEVER WANT TO DO ANYTHING IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE PERPETRATOR
AGAIN. FOR LARGE HAVE TO
BALANCE THE RIGHTS OF EVERYONE
AND SO I IN NO WAY WANT TO DENY
THE EXPERIENCE OF THE VICTIM
WHO CALLED IN BUT IN TRYING TO.
THREAD THE NEEDLE IN TERMS OF
RESPECTING THE RIGHTS OF ALL
CONCERNED IN CONSTRUCTING A LAW
IT SEEMED LIKE IT. IT WITH
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
OTHERS IT WAS I FELT THE
APPROPRIATE AMENDMENTS. NOW AND
AGAIN I AM IN IN THE COMMON I'M
ABOUT TO MAKE I DO NOT MEAN TO
IMPLY IN ANY WAY THAT MS MENDEZ
WHO SPOKE IS IN IT SHE SHE
EXPERIENCE WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCED. BUT IN WHAT SHE
COMMUNICATED SHE INDICATED THAT
THAT WAS THE FAMILY MEMBERS. OF
HER PERPETRATOR. AND EVEN IF WE
WERE TO PASS THE LAW AS
PRESENTED TO US RIGHT NOW
WITHOUT THE MINUTE. HE WOULD
ONLY BE A RESTRAINING ORDER ON
THE INDIVIDUAL ON THE
PERPETRATOR AND NOT ON THE
FAMILY MEMBERS SO IT WOULD NOT
I MEAN IT IS HORRIBLE WHAT SHE
EXPERIENCED AND NO ONE SHOULD
HAVE TO EXPERIENCE THAT. BUT
THIS LAW WOULD NOT HAVE
PREVENTED THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS
FROM DOING WHATEVER THEY DID.
NOW LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER ON THE- I'M CENTER
JACKSON AND SENATOR WIENER YEAH
I DIDN'T GET IT. I REMEMBER WAY
BACK WHEN I WAS A YOUNG
PROSECUTOR- YOU HAD-
INDIVIDUALS WHO FOR WHATEVER
REASON URINATED IN PUBLIC AND
HAD TO REGISTER AS SEX
OFFENDERS ALONG WITH PEOPLE WHO
WERE TRUE. SEX OFFENDER SO I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT WE
RECOGNIZED THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE- SOME DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
THE OFFENSES THAT HAVE BEEN
CATEGORIZED AS A SEX OFFENSE.
REGISTRATION CRIMES- I THINK
THE PROPOSAL THAT. YOU
RECOMMEND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE BAD THE REALLY BAD PEOPLE.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY WILL
HAVE A LIFETIME THE PAROLE
BOARDS OVER WHICH HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER THEM
POTENTIALLY FOR THE COURSE OF
THEIR LIVES WE'LL BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT DECISION. I ALSO
THINK WE NEED TO GIVE THE COURT
SOME. DISCRETION IN HIS IS
WELL IF A PERSON NEEDS TO COME
IN FOR WHATEVER REASON AFTER A
TEN YEAR PERIOD- TO RENEW A-
RESTRAINING ORDER IF YOU WILL I
THINK THAT THAT IS OF AS I
UNDERSTAND ALREADY AVAILABLE.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION. IS IF I
MAY MAN CHAIR TO THE AUTHOR IS
WHY ARE YOU ONE WILLING TO
ACCEPT. THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED BY- THE CHAIR AND BY
THE COMMITTEE- IN ORDER TO.
MAKE THIS I THINK WHAT WILL BE
AS YOU SAY WE HAVE A NEED A WE%
HAVE TO THREAD HERE WHETHER WE
LIKE IT OR NOT- IF YOU COULD
RESPOND BECAUSE I AM INCLINED
TO FOLLOW THE DIRECTION OF THE
CHAIR. WHICH MEANS I WILL NOT
BE VOTING FOR THIS AND I
SUSPECT THERE ARE OTHERS WHO
MAY. DO THE SAME- SO I'D LIKE
TO PERHAPS HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY YOU ARE
UNWILLING TO TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS. I JUST GO AHEAD
SEND RINGTONE COMMANDCHECK. UP
WE YOU KNOW. I DON'T DISAGREE
WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH AT THE
COMMENTS MADE HERE BY BY
COMPARISON THE CONCERNS. ARE
OUT WE DEFINITELY DON'T I
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO- YOU
KNOW HAVE IT APPLY. IN A
BROADLY WAY BUT I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT WE DON'T
NARROWED SO MUCH THAT IT
DOESN'T APPLY TO THE- TO OUR
VICTIMS THAT WERE. THAT WERE
FIGHTING ON BEHALF OF AND SO.
THE LANGUAGE THAT WAS PRESENTED
TO US- I MEAN WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH WHAT THE
COMMITTEE- STAFF AND EVEN WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
TO MAKE THE NECESSARY
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THIS WORK-
BUT WE DON'T. WE DON'T
NECESSARILY BELIEVE THAT THE-AMENDMENTS. THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO US WOULD FIT- DID BE TOO
NARROW FOR OUR VICTIMS OF WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO PROTECT. MAY I
ASK ONE POINT A CLASS
CUNNINGHAM JACKSON MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE BILL
DOESN'T NARROW EXISTING LAW. HL
SIMPLY THE FINES AND IDENTIFIES
THE BAD THE TRULY THE WORST
OFFENDERS AND CREATES THE
POTENTIAL FOR A LIFETIME-
RESTRAINING ORDER AS A
CONDITION OF PAROLE. SO IN IT
DO YOU DISAGREE WITH ADAM I
MISSED READING THE BILL.
THROUGH THE CHAIR GO AHEAD
AUTHOR. AT THE WHITE I AGREE
WITH YOU BUT- BASED ON THE
LANGUAGE THAT I HAVE I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT. IT PROTECTS THE
VICTIMS THAT WERE LOOKING TO
REPRESENT. OKAY THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER. THANKS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I DID HAVE
A CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR-
YESTERDAY- ABOUT THIS AND I
WANNA JUST APPRECIATE THE WORK-
THAT YOU'RE DOING I THINK YOU
ARE YOU'RE TRYING TO HELP
VICTIMS PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
YOU KNOW TERRIBLY HARMS AND-
THE YOU MIGHT MISS BUT THE
WITNESS. ACCOUNT BEFORE I KNOW
NO ONE EVER EVER HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE AND- SOMEONE WHO
WOULD DO THAT TO ANOTHER HUMAN
BEING- SHOULD NOT SEE THE LIGHT
VICTIMS NEED TO BE PROTECTED SO
DODD. THIS ISN'T ABOUT. ON BAD
IN TERMS OF DISCUSSION WE'RE
HAVING TODAY- AS I MENTIONED TO
YOU YESTERDAY WITH CHAIRS
AMENDMENTS I WOULD BE. WILLING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THE MANY
AT THE TWO OR THREE WHEN WE-
WHEN WE PASSED THE REFORM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT WAS. THE
CULMINATION OF YEARS AND YEARS
OF WORK IT WAS IN A CONSTANT
FAILURE FAILURE FAILURE AND WE
FINALLY ASSEMBLED THE COALITION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT-
TO UNDERSTAND SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY WAS A DISASTER IT
STILL IS BECAUSE- TECHNICALLY
DOESN'T GO INTO EFFECT THESE
CHANGES UNTIL. THE END OF THIS
YEAR TO COMPLETE USELESS
DISASTER WITH ONE FOUR HUNDRED
CALIFORNIANS ON SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY. FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE TO THE
POINT WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN'T DO ANYTHING WITH IT IN
TERMS OF IDENTIFYING WHO WERE
THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY.
PRESCOTT WE HAVE X. FOR THE
PEOPLE YOU'RE IN IT IN PUBLIC
OR THE- YOU KNOW THE GUYS WHO
HAD SEX IN A PARK IN NINETEEN
SIXTY WHO STONE THE REGISTRY-
AND THEN WE HAVE. STREAM AND OF
THE PREDATORS WHO WERE TALK
JUST HORRIFIC HUMAN BEINGS.
THERE'S A MASSIVE SPECTRUM
BETWEEN INCLUDING ANSWER TO. ON
AND SO- IT SO WE CREATED THIS
YEAR'S IT WASN'T PERFECT. IT'S
STILL NOT. PERFECT BUT IT WAS
WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO AND WE
GOT HAT PASSED INTO LAW AND
ARE GOING TO AFFECTS SOON- IF
THIS WERE LIMITED TO TIER
THREE. I WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM
SUPPORTING IT YOU KNOW THE
CRIME TO TIER THREE ARE. JUST
IT SUGGESTS THERE. COULD NOT AN
ISSUE- BUT I THINK THE BREADTH
OF THE BILL NOW IS A THIS IS A
STEP TOO FAR FOR ME AS I
EXPRESSED TO. I ESTAS
APPRECIATE WHAT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO- CREDIT FOR DOING
THAT AND I AND I THANK YOU FOR
TRYING TO STEP UP TO THESE.
VICTIMS BUT THIS IS JUST A IT'S
A- IT'S A STEP OO FAR- FOR ME
SO- I HOPE- RECONSIDER IF YOU
DO THE BILL AGAIN. YOU KNOW-
RECONSIDER- BUT THAT'S FINE I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY UNFORTUNATELY. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THE- ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FROM MEMBERS. GREAT SEEING NINE
A SENATOR HER DAUGHTER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I JUST
WANT TO AB YOU KNOW EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO THE CHAIR AND TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND OF COURSE IT IS A COMMITTEE
STAFF OF FOR WORKING WITH MY
TEAM AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
TRY TO GET THE CIS CLOSE AS
POSSIBLE AND- I NOTE THAT. THIS
IS THIS IS JUST THE START OF A
CONVERSATION AND I THINK ON THE
SAME PAGE AND SO I KNOW THAT
THAT- THAT IF IT DOESN'T GET
THROUGH THE DAY THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE MAKE IT BETTER SO
IT WORKS FOR ALL OF US AND SO I
THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT. SO
THANK YOU. I AM. THANK YOU AND
I THINK THE MOST OF THE MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE DíAS WOULD
YEAR THE MORNING TO. REJECT
THOSE VICTIMS FROM HAVING TO.
BASICALLY HAVE TO GO BACK TO
COURT AGAIN AND AGAIN SINCE WE
KNOW THAT ALREADY DEAR IS THE
SEXUAL CRIMES JUST IN AN OF
THEIR NATURE PEOPLE REPORT THEM
LESS JUST BECAUSE OF THE NOT
EVEN WANTING TO GO THROUGH THE
EXPERIENCE OF HAVING TO- REPORT
N. B. I MEAN THIS. THE WHETHER
IT'S SHAME OR- WONDERING
WHETHER YOU WOULD BE EVEN
CONSIDERED CREDIBLE SO WE KNOW
THEY'RE ALL THOSE ELEMENTS BUT
IN AS WE'VE DISCUSSED IN.
TRYING TO CRAFT ANY STATUTE WE
HAVE TO BALANCE ALL THE RIGHTS-
SO I AM. I THINK WE ARE. WE
CERTAINLY TRIED OUR BEST TO
COME UP WITH AN AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE EXPRESSED BY YOUR
ADVOCATES- IN YOUR BILL
SPONSORED- BUT I CAN SEE NOW
THAT IT DOESN'T QUITE DO WHAT
YOU NEEDED TO DO BUT I THINK
THE BILL SAY FIRST BEFORE AS
RIGHT NOW IS FOR MYSELF TOO
BROAD. AND SO I WILL BE NOT
SUPPORT STAY OFF AND WITH THAT
LET'S SEE IS THERE ANY. ANY
MOTION ON THE BILL OR SHOULD WE
CAN. THE RIGHT SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND- LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL. MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER. MORE
LOCK. BRADFORD JACKSON.
MITCHELL. BURL HI I WIENER
WIENER NOW VOTERS OF ONE ONE
BILL FAILS. THE PHONE BILL
FAILS OF. I'D I'D WE I DON'T
THINK IN THIS YEAR WE WOULD-
EVERY CONSIDERATION IS NOT
REALLY AVAILABLE THIS YEAR IS
THAT CORRECT THERE WOULD BE NO
TIME TO HEAR THE BILL BRITT SO.
OTHERWISE I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
GRITTED BUT I DON'T THINK IN
THIS CONTEXT WE SO ANYWAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- WELCOME
TO THE CONVERSATION TO THANK
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER.
CORRECT. WE ARE GOING TO OUR
NEXT BILL. SO WE WILL NOW HEAR
SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX SENATOR
UMBERG AND THAT IS ON PRICE
GOUGING. AND I BELIEVE YOUR KEY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORTER ON THE
LINE BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PHONE FOR OTHER FOLKS
IS PUT UP ON THE SCREEN JUST SO
PEOPLE KNOW. SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE SAME WE CAN PROCEED
TO- EXPEDITIOUSLY SENATOR
UMBERG GO AHEAD PRESENT YOUR
BILL OF THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- LET ME BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. ALSO I KNOW THE
PRESENCE OF MOSES HERE IN
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M SORRY THAT
SENATOR MORLOCK. MORNING
SENATOR. SO WHAT WHAT YOU HAVE.
YEAH BUT MY PEOPLE GO. A MAN
CHAIR MEMBERS- YEAH BEFORE YOU
SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX- AS A
RESULT IS EXPERIENCED DURING
THE PANDEMIC THEY'VE BEEN
INCREDIBLE STORIES OF OUR
NEIGHBORS AND FRIENDS AND
OTHERS- STEPPING UP TO HELP
EACH OTHER SADLY THERE ARE VERY
FEW A VERY FEW IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE USE THIS PANDA LIKE
THIS CRISIS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THEIR NEIGHBORS. AND THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL AS YOU
GOVERNOR'S ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT- DURING THE PERIOD
OF EMERGENCY MAKES PRICE
GOUGING IS BILLED AS THE FIGHT
BY RAISING THE PRICE OF A GOOD.
MORE THAN 10% OVER THE PREVIOUS
PRODUCTS. THAT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS THIS BILL CODIFIES THAT
IT ALSO- PROVIDES. WHERE IS A
BUSINESS HAS NOT BEEN SELLING A
PARTICULAR GOOD BUT GETS IN THE
BUSINESS FOR EXAMPLE SELLING
HAND SANITIZER AND THEN-
ENGAGES IN PRICE GOUGING THAT
THEY ALSOMAY BE PUNISHED. ONE
ASPECT OF THE BILL THAT IS ALSO
NEW AND THAT'S THAT- IF ONE. UP
PROFITS BY MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THEN THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAS THE
DISCRETION TO CHARGE THIS IS
EITHER MISDEMEANOR OR A FELONY.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE- IF YOU ARE A LARGE
pGOUGE. MISTER MEANER FOR A
LARGE SCALE OPERATION IT IS
REALLY JUST A PARKING TICKET.
AND A FELONY WILL BOTH I THINK
SEND A MESSAGE SHOULD THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY DECIDED TO
CHOOSE IT AND ALSO. IT WILL
BECAUSE- LARGER ENTITIES TO HAS
SOME PAUSE. BEFORE THE ENGAGE
IN PRICE GOUGING- WITH ME- OR
ACTUALLY ON THE LINE- THERE ARE
TWO WITNESSES- FIRST- LESLIE
YOUNG ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CONSUMER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL FRAUDS UNIT. AT
THE ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN TOM. PAPA
GEORGE HEAD OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION UNIT SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE I SHOULD ALSO NOTE
MATTER MAN SURE THAT THE YEARS
STAFF HAS WORKED VERY. ON THE
CIVIC STYLE. AND DONE SOME VERY
GOOD WORK WITH US- APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK BY MIKE THANK YOU
LET'S SEE HERE FOR YOUR
pWITNESSES AND- BUT I WILL SAY
THEIR NAME SO THEY CAN GO IN
ORDER. THE FIRST- MISS LESLEE
YOUNG A GREAT AND THEN THOMAS
PAPA GEORGE K. GREAT AND YOU
HAVE TOTAL THREE MINUTES GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS LESLIE YOUNG AND I AM THE
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
CHARGE OF THE CONSUMER FRAUD
UNIT AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. ON
BEHALF OF ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TODD THAT SIR
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR-
BURKE FOR CARRYING THIS BILL
AND IT IS OUR HONOR TO CO
SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION. WITH
THE DANTE AGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. IN EARLY
MARCH WE SET UP A HOTLINE FOR
THE CITIZENS OF ORANGE COUNTY
TO REPORT INCIDENTS OF PRICE
GOUGING. IN THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS WE RECEIVED OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CALL. WE
LEARNED QUICKLY THAT THE
MAJORITY OF ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS. CONTACTED OR BETTER
THAN THAT ONE TO FOLLOW THE LAW
AND VOLUNTARILY PROVIDED OUR
INVESTIGATORS WITH THE- WE
NEEDED. TO DETERMINE IF PRICE
GOUGING HAD OCCURRED BUT IN A
SMALL MINORITY OF CASES WE
ENCOUNTERED UNCOOPERATIVE
BUSINESSES THAT WERE SELLING
ESSENTIAL ITEMS LIKE THEY NOW.
YEAH OUTSIDE THE NOT OLD PRIOR
TO THE EMERGING DECLARATION.
SHE. THESE ARE NOT GOOD ACTORS
WHO MADE IT. AND WANTED TO. ONE
TWO ARE WILLINGLY. OFF THE OF A-
MAKING PRICE GOUGING AWAY BLUR
THAT CAN BE A FELONY WHEN THE
UNLAWFUL PROFIT IS GREATER THAN
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IS A FAIR
WAY TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS A
SUFFICIENT DISINCENTIVES TO THE
LARGEST PRICE GOUGING SCHEME.
WHILE CONTINUING TO TREAT THE
SMALL RETAILERS WITH THE
LENIENCY THEY DESERVE WE URGE
AND I'D VOTE ON THIS BILL AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS MR PAPAGEORGIOU. YES
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TOM PAPA GEORGE WITH
THE SAN DIEGO DA'S OFFICE. I'M
PROUD TO SAY THAT I HELPED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RICHARD KATZ
DRAFTS THE ORIGINAL PENAL CODE
SECTION THREE NINETY SIX. AFTER
THE SAN FERNANDO EARTHQUAKE IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AND OVER
THE YEARS IT'S BEEN A VALUABLE
TOOL TO HELP US. CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS FROM PRICE GOUGING.
BUT THE CURRENT EMERGENCY SHOWS
THAT WE NEED TO UPDATE THE LAW.
THIS BILL PROVIDES TWO
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS IT
CLARIFIES THAT THE PRICE
GOUGING LAW APPLIES TO. ALL TO
CLEAR EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
INCLUDING PANDEMICS AND ALSO
APPLIES THE LAW EQUALLY TO ALL
SELLERS ONLINE SELLERS AS WELL
AS BRICK AND MORTAR RETAILERS.
THE CURRENT LAW ONLY COVERS
BUSINESSES THAT SOLD BEFORE AN
EMERGENCY AND THAT WAS THE
CONCERN BACK IN NINETY FOUR
EXTENDS THE LAW TO COVER NEW
SELLERS AS WELL. SO THAT IT
FLIES FAIRLY TO ALL BUSINESSES
IN THE MARKETPLACE. A LARGE
SCALE PRICE GUIDE YOU CAN BE
VERY SERIOUS YOU CAN EVEN
THREATEN HEALTH AND SAFETY.
SUCH AS A CASE WERE
INVESTIGATING PRESENTLY IN
NINETY FIVE MASKS BEING SOLD
FOR TEN TIMES THEIR COST. AS
THE SENATORS POINT OUT THAT
MISDEMEANORS SOMETIMES DON'T TO
ADEQUATELY DETER LARGER
BUSINESSES. SO THIS BILL
PROVIDES FOR AN ALTERNATE
FELONY MISDEMEANOR BUT WITH A
VERY IMPORTANT SAFEGUARD. THE
FELONY IS ONLY AVAILABLE IN
CASES OF PRICE GOUGING SALES OF
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE.
SO THE FAMILY CAN ONLY BE USED
FOR THE MOST SERIOUS CASES WE
THINK THAT'S A FAIR AND
APPROPRIATE APPROACH I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU YOUR GREAT JUST A- JUST
THREE MINUTES. A SUPPORTERS OF
THE BILL. MODERATOR YOU MAY
RECOGNIZE THEIR LINES NOW AND
ALLOW THEM TO WEIGH IN
MODERATOR. I ONCE AGAIN DOES IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS TO ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE TO GET YOUR LINE
NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN ALL THOSE IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE AND IN THE
ZERO AND AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE SEVERAL
QUEUING UP. OKAY AND THE HAS
THE KEY WHEN I DID NOT SEE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WALKED
IN OF A BUT I SHOULD ASK IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WANTED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. FINE DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
SECOND FLOOR ROOM BUT YOU CAN
SHOW ME ON THE SCREEN. I DON'T
THINK THAT PERSON IS HEARD
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OUR
ITSELF MODERATOR GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY ONE NAY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE COLD WAR LIMóN ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BACK IN MARC
ANTHONY HALF OF THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND I KELLY
ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
EMOLLIENT SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LINE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK TURN AND THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA BOTH
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS OF ANTHONY LIVE ON
BEHALF OF VETERAN GENERAL BUT
THEIR OWN I'M PLEASED TO REPORT
AT ELEVEN NINETY. THANK YOU AND
LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS WEEK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP
STRONGLY IN COURT. THANK YOU
LINE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MARTEL CUT ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY NINE IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GREEN
GARDEN CONFINED THERE YOU GO
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NINE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MATTHEWS ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BRIAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
IN COURT. THANK YOU AND I'M
SHOWING NOW WHAT THE RESPONSES
AT THIS TIME. ALRIGHT WE WILL
GO TO THE- OPPONENTS AND OF
COURSE IF THERE WAS ANYONE IN
SUPPORT DO WE DIDN'T WILL COME
BACK TO YOU JUST- WE KNOW THIS-
PROCESSES ON USUAL BUT SO NOW-
THE KEY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I BELIEVE THERE'S ONE OR MAYBE
IT'S A TWEENER AND THAT IS
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FROM
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION MODERATE ALLOW. HER
TO SPEAK PLEASE. HER LINE IS
OPEN. CLOSELY YOU CAN ON MUTE
THEN YOU CAN PROCEED. I'M SORRY
LET'S SEE PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE BUTTON. AND IS THIS LESLIE
YOUNG NODE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
GETTING LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON.
OKAY AND I'M NOT SHOWING HER ON
THE LINE AS OF YET. AND LESLIE
IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE AND
DIALED THE WRONG NUMBER. YOU
MAY PRESS. ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND TELL THE OPERATOR TO TAKE
YOUR NAME. ONCE AGAIN LESLIE IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE AND PRESSED
THE WRONG NUMBER PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO THANK YOU THE
OPERATOR YOUR NAME AND TELL
THEM YOU NEED AN OPEN LINE. ONE
MOMENT. CERTAINLY. I'M NOT
GETTING A RESPONSE TO SHOW
MISUSED AND IS ON THE LINE. A.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE WHO WANT TO
INDICATE THEIR EITHER TWEENER
OPPOSITION AND THEN WE'LL GIVE
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON-
OPPORTUNITY THERE TO RECALL AND
IF THERE WAS SOME PROBLEM WITH
THE LINE MODERATOR LET'S JUST
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO
WAS GOING TO TESTIFY IN EITHER
TWEENER OPPOSITION. TWEENER
BEING- THEY WOULD SUPPORT IF-
CHANGED COMMENDED. GO AHEAD
MODERATOR. AND FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND
AGAIN PRESS ONE AND IN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND. AND ONE
MOMENT BUT HE. MADAM CHAIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES I CAN HEAR YOU.
SH BUT MICHAEL DR OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU AND WE WANTED TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION FOR A BI
AUTHORS OFFICER MY CANADIAN
COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR THE
ONGOING DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS
BILL WE HAVE FREE- SOME
CONCERNS- NAMELY ABOUT-
INSURING THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T
EXPAND- CRIMINAL. PROSECUTION
OR OR ENFORCEMENT OF LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE- DURING THIS I PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. WE APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE ON GOING WORK WE
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT HE-
AMENDMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A LESLIE
HE IF SHE IS ON MODERATOR
PLEASE TELL OR WHAT SHE WOULD
NEED TO DO TO BE ABLE TO WIN AT
THIS POINT. THAT'S PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND. AND ONE MOMENT
LET ME JUST SEE IF YOU HAVE AN
OPEN LINE. AND SHE DOES NOT
SELL WITH HOUSTON IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE. PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND THAT THE OPERATOR NO
WHEN THEY TAKE YOUR NAME. THAT
YOU NEED AN OPEN LINE. ONCE
AGAIN PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
TELL THE OPERATOR YOUR NAME AND
THAT YOU NEED AN OPEN LINE IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE. OTHERWISE
WE HAD TWO OTHER PEOPLE RESPOND.
ARE YOU CAN MOVE TO THEM. A
LINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS DENNIS I'LL BE
ANI I WE ARE A TWEENER AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GRAIN AND FEED
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WHERE
ELSE ASSOCIATION BEING THE
GOVERNOR BEING SHIPPERS
CALIFORNIA C. SUFFICIENT AND
ASSOCIATES CALIFORNIA EGG
FARMERS AMONG OTHERS OUR
CONCERN IS NOT NO HARM THEIR
LUDGATE BOCA IT THIS POINT YOU
CAN JUST SAY WHAT YOU SAID SO.
A I STILL HAVE TO GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MY OFFICIAL.
OPPONENT TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK SO
MISTER ALBEE ANI WILL JUST
RECORD THAT YOU'RE A TWEENER.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING THIS IS LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON I'M SORRY I'M
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL PROBLEMS
I AM THIRTY SECONDS WE ARE YOU
MAY AND WE CAN GO BACK TO ALL
BE ON IF YOU ONLY TAKE THIRTY
SECONDS SO GO AHEAD. OKAY I
JUST WANTED TO STATE THAT
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON'S ON
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE NOT
FORMALLY OPPOSING HOWEVER WE DO
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR. THRESHOLD
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T THE AGGREGATE
AND THIS DOES NOT DEAL WITH THE
IDEA THAT THE BILL IS TO GO
AFTER. CORPORATION THE LARGE
BUSINESSES. FOR HOME A
MISDEMEANOR MAY MEAN NOTHING
BUT THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
LANGUAGE DOES ALLOW FOR THE
AGGREGATE AND IT STILL LEAVES
THE DOOR OPEN. TO JUDGE MALL
BUSINESSES AND THE POOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- MR ABI ON IF
YOU'RE STILL ON THE LINE YOU
CAN EXPLAIN WHAT IT IS THAT.
BRIEFLY MODERATOR YOU CAN OF
RECOGNIZE MISTRAL PEONIES. WE
STILL HAVE THIRTY SECONDS OVER
THREE MINUTES. AND SIR IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR AND
AGAIN JUST VERY QUICKLY FOR ALL
COMMODITY ENTITIES BASED SOME
OF THE INTERNATIONAL NATIONAL
AND OBVIOUSLY THE STATE
MARKETS. AND THE UNDERLYING
BILL DOES NOT RECOGNIZE. IF
PRICE FLUCTUATIONS ESPECIALLY
IN SOMETHING LIKE A PANDEMIC
WHERE THE INTERNATIONAL OR
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS. BUT TO
CONCLUDE THE PRINTED THE BIG
CHICAGO MERCANTILE EXCHANGE MAY
SHIFTING GO UP MORE THAN TEN
PERCENT. AND THEN- WE WOULD BE
IN VIOLATION OF THIS BILL AS A
TERRIBLE LAWS IT'S WRITTEN AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY FELONY NOW BUT
THE BILL SO WE'D LIKE TO WE
PROVIDE SOME SOME- AMENDMENTS
TO THE TO THE OFFICER THERE.
WERE LOOKED AS TOO BROAD SO
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT. BOAT BUT
THIS IS THE REAL ISSUE THAT
ENTITIES THAT ARE SO INUNDATED
TIONAL INTERNATIONAL REMARK.
MAY TO BE DEL WITH DIFFERENTLY
JUST BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE A
DISINCENTIVE TO SELL INTO THE
CALIFORNIA- INTO THE EMERGENCY
AREA. IF YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE
ENTITIES AND FRANKLY WE DON'T
WANT THAT YOU WANT PRODUCT
MOVING INTO THE- EMERGENCY
AREAS SO- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND WE HAVE
SPOKEN OF THE- THE STAFF WILL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. LOS TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY JUST REGULAR PUBLIC
OR NOT REGULAR PLUG PEOPLE JUST
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT ARTIFICIAL-
OPPONENTS ARE TRAINERS WHO JUST
WANT TO SAY THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND WEIGH IN
MODERATOR ALLOW THEM AT THE
RISE WILL GO TO THE DíAS NEVER
DISCUSSION. AND THANK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO WEIGH IN PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO TO GET YOUR
LINE NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO WAY N. PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ILLINOIS ACTIVITY NOW
ONCE AGAIN IT TO ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO WEIGH IN.
AND I'M SHOWING NO RESPONSE AT
THIS TIME. ALRIGHT SO WE WILL
TURN TO THE DíAS NOW FOR
DISCUSSION SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD PRICE GOUGING IS. IT'S
A REAL ISSUE AND- YOU KNOW I
COMMEND YOU FOR- FOR DRESSING
WITH THIS BILL. TIME AS I
MENTIONED YOU WHEN WE SPOKE
THIS MORNING- I HAVE A CONCERN
WITH ONE SPECIFIC ASPECT OF THE
BILL. AND THAT IS A PROVISION
THAT IF YOU HAVE NOT PREVIOUSLY
SOLD AN ITEM SO IT'S A NEW ITEM
THAT YOU'RE SELLING- YOU CAN
NOT MARKET UP MORE THAN FIFTY
PERCENT. BASED ON WHAT YOU PAID
FOR IT- AND THIS COULD BE A
SITUATION WHERE AS A YOU KNOW
SOMEONE WHO YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
IT'S DESIGNED FOR SITUATION
WERE. A BUSINESS DESIGNS
DECIDES YOU KNOW SOMEONE STARTS
ON MASKS AND- NO GOING TO PAY
FIFTY CENTS FIFTY CENTS FOR
THEM AND S
LLARS OR- YOU KNOW BUT IT
ALSO APPLIES IF THE STORE- FOR
EXAMPLE SIGNED CLEANING
PRODUCTS THEY SOLD FOR A LONG
TIME BUT NOW. BECAUSE OF SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES WHATEVER THEIR
SHIFT TO A NEW BROWN. THEN BE
PRECLUDED FROM MARKING THAT OUT
MORE THAN FIFTY FOR. GAR LISTS
OF WHAT THEY- CHARGE FOR THE
PREVIOUS. BRAND TODAY CAN NO
LONGER ACCESS. AND SO IT'S A
VERY BLUNT INSTRUMENT- AND I
KNOW THAT I THINK THIS. I
ASSUME THIS IS COMING FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
ALSO. APPLY THE 50% BUT I EVEN
BEFORE THIS BILL IS ON MY RADAR
ONE OF THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER- I GOT OUT REACH FROM
HARDWARE STORES- IN MY DISTRICT
THAT I KNOW THAT. I GUESS THERE
MAY BE NO CALIFORNIA HARDWARE
ASSOCIATION WE GOT THE LETTER
FROM THE NATIONAL. THE NORTH
AMERICAN RETAIL HARDWARE
ASSOCIATION INDIANAPOLIS THEIR
OFFICES AND TESTIFIED TODAY
THEY SENT A LETTER. CERTAINLY
IN THE PROCESS OF SO BE IT I
GUESS THE HARVESTERS MAYBE
AREN'T AS ORGANIZED IN
CALIFORNIA OR DON'T HAVE A
LOBBYIST- AND SO THIS HAS AND
AS- AS PART OF THE CONVERSATION
BUT- THE CONCERN IS THAT FOR
EXAMPLE IF A HARDWARE STORE.
HAS TO SHIFT TO A NEW. CLEANING
PRODUCT. AND LET'S SAY THEY'RE
PAYING. A DOLLAR FIFTY FOR THAT
CLEANING PRODUCT. BAY WOULD BE
PRECLUDED FOM CHARGING MORE
THAN TWO DOLLARS AND TWENTY
FIVE CENTS FOR IT. SO TWO
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS WILL BE
CONSIDER PRICE GOUGING EVEN
THOUGH I THINK MOST PEOPLE
LOOKING AT THAT. WOULD SAY
THAT'S NOT PRICE HOUSING- AND
THE CHALLENGES THAT IN TERMS OF
JUST COVERING THEIR OWN COSTS.
OF STAFF OF. OVERHEAD IT CETERA
ETCETERA- ACCORDING TO A-
HARDWARE STORE IN OUR MY
DISTRICT TO I'VE SPOKEN TO THE
WHITE OF PHENOMENAL BUSINESS
LONG TIME HUNDRED YEAR OLD
FAMILY BUSINESS. WHO I TRUST
AND THAT IS A GOOD ACTOR.
THEY'RE THEY'RE GONNA LOSE
MONEY- ON THESE- PRODUCTS. AND
SO THAT IS A REAL CONCERN- FOR
ME I'VE BEEN FIFTY PERCENT-
EVEN THOUGH IT SOUNDS GOOD WHEN
YOU READ IT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
AND THEN THE OTHER CONTACTS
WERE ALREADY OFFERING- NOT
BEING ABLE TO RAISE MORE THAN
TEN PERCENT. THAT MAKES ALL THE
SENSE SENSE IN THE WORLD
ALREADY AS A BUSINESS IT'S A
PRICE. AND IF YOU'RE NOW
RAISING IT DURING AN EMERGENCY
MORE THAN 10% WE KNOW WHY
YOU'RE DOINGTHAT. BUT THE 50%
I THINK IS NOT VALID. AND HI
MARTY DESIRE WOULD BE FOR THAT
TO COME OUT OF THE BILL- WE'VE
CONVEYED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THAT WE- THINK IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE ON THE EXECUTIVE
BOARD- BUT IT'S- AN ACTIVITY
WITH THAT. FIFTY I'M- YOU KNOW
GOING. HOLD OFF ON THE BILL.
I'D LIKE TO GO TO VOTE THE FLOW.
THE RICHEST TALK THAT ISSUE A
LITTLE BIT MANAGER WAS LIKE TO
BE TO RESPOND MY CLOTHES OR YOU
MAY RESPOND NOW SENATOR AMBER
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER AND YES YOU'RE RIGHT WE
HAD THE CONVERSATION AND I
THINK YOU THERE HAVE BEEN A
COUPLE VALID POINTS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED HERE. ONE IS THAT-
THE BILL DOES NOT- TAKE INTO.
ITS CALCULATION. THE FIXED
COSTS. FOR THE HIGHER LABOR
COSTS SO FOR EXAMPLE SAN
FRANCISCO- WHERE THE FIXED
COSTS ARE PROBABLY HIGHER THAN
OTHER PLACES STATE LABOR MAY BE
HIGHER THAN OTHER PLACES THE
STATE. THAT WE WILL WORK WITH
YOU AND OTHERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WERE FIXED COSTS IN
LABOR COSTS AND OTHER COSTS.
BASICALLY DON'T INCREASE THE
PROFIT THAT'S OR AFTER WERE
AFTER FOLKS WHO ALSO GET THE
FACEMASK BUSINESS AND AS YOU
POINT OUT. BY FACE MASK FOR
FIFTY CENTS IS ALL FOR TWENTY
DOLLARS. AND SO- WILL WORK ON
THE LANGUAGE TO SEE IF WE
CAN'T- A CRAFTED SUCH A IT
DRESSES THAT ISSUE OTHER PLACES
IN THE BILL. YOU TALK ABOUT 10%
INCREASE DUE. OF FOCUS ON OTHER
COST SIGHS COST OF ACQUISITION
OF THE PARTICULAR PRODUCT.
THAT'S THAT'S ITEM ONE AND WILL
CONTINUE WORK ON THAT I HAD TO
IS WITH RESPECT TO CALL BODIES
SUCH AS WE EAT- THE BILL-
FOCUSES ON. CONCERT PERCHED SO
I SUPPOSE THAT THE CONSUMER
WHICH IS TO PURCHASE A BUSHEL
WHEAT. AND THE FROM OF THE A
SUPPLIER WE WILL ALSO ON TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT SOMEHOW IF
THE INTERNATIONAL MARKET
INCREASES THE PRICE OF WHEAT OR
CORN OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND
YOU WANT TO BUY A BUSHEL CORN
THAT THAT THE SUPPLIER IF
THEY'RE SELLING IT AT THE
MARKET RATE WILL BE A
POTENTIALLY TACT- BUT AND I AND
I ALSO GET THAT THIS IS LITTLE.
CONSOLATION BUT BUT DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS DO HAVE DISCRETION SO
MY EXPECTATION IS A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IS NOT GOING TO CHARGE
SOMEONE WHO BUYS A BUSHEL OF
WHEAT- AT MARKET PRICE FOR- OR
EXCUSE ME WHO SELLS BUSHEL
WHEAT AT MARKET PRICE OF WITH
PRICE GOUGING BUT THANK YOU
EIGHT- IF I MIGHT JUST GO AHEAD
YES SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT SO I'M GOING TO I'M GOING
TO I'M NOT FOR THE BILL TODAY-
I'LL STAY OFF I IN MY DESIRES
TO VOTE FOR ON THE FLOOR OF MY
STAFFERS SO TO YOUR STAFF MAYBE
ONE GAME SOME OF THE LOCAL
HARDWARE STORES TALK ABOUT IT I
APPRECIATE YOUR OPEN THIS. THE
HOPE IN THE FUTURE BUT- THE
POINT HARPER SORT BE. MAYBE OR
A LITTLE MORE. AND GET INVOLVED
EARLY BECAUSE IN FAIRNESS TO.
THIS WAS. AT THE LAST MINUTE-
BINATIONAL ORGANIZATION SO
WE'LL WORK ON THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR WE
HAVE. A CENTER MORE LIKE IN THE
IN A SENATOR JACKSON'S GOOD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I. JUST
WANTED MAYBE INDULGE ME AND
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF ANYBODY'S WATCHING WHAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY. DEALING WITH
HERE SPLINE DEMAND IS KEY
FUNDAMENTAL ASPECT OF THE
ECONOMY SO WILL WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DEFINE PRICE GOUGING
PROPERLY AND IN ORDER FREE
MARKET PRINCIPLES WE WORSE
WE'RE SITTING UNDERNEATH.
INCREDIBLE MOSAIC AND DURING
THE GOLD RUSH. YOU PAPER THE
AYE PRICES FOR A EXISTS IN
FOODSTUFFS IN THE RETAILERS ARE
ACTUALLY THE REAL MONEY MAKERS-
LELAND STANFORD. YOU KNOW THAT
JUST ASSIST SUCCESS STORY
BECAUSE HE COULD CHARGE HIGH
PRICES LIKE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE REALLY CLEAR THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. A
EITHER BY THE GOVERNOR OR BY
THE PRESENT UNITED STATES-
BECAUSE THERE ARE RETAILERS
THAT- RECENTLY WITH A P. S. P.
S. WHEN THE POWER SHORTAGE OR
POWER SHUT OFF THE DAY HAD TO
GIVE THEIR FOOD AWAY AND
FREEZERS WRITER IS LIKE THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE SO I'M I'M JUST
CURIOUS BUT A COUPLE THINGS ONE
IS THE EFFICACY OF. 10% AND A
50% BECAUSE- 40% YOU KNOW
YOU'RE SO I'M JUST COULD COULD
JUST HELP ME OUT AND I'M GLAD
YOU GOT TO YOU HAD THE MISTER
PAPA GEORGE ON TH LINE AND HE
SEEMS LIKE HE USED STATED HE
WAS THERE FOR THE ORIGINAL
OUTSIDE I I'D LIKE JUST FOR YOU
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT PRICE GOUGING AND WHAT IT
IS AND- WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
QUANTIFY BUT LET ME SEE IF I
CAN MANAGER IF I MIGHT RESPOND
AND LET ME SAN DIEGO OUT. I CAN
RESPOND THAT MR PAPA GEORGE CAN
SUPPLEMENT CORRECT ME THAT BE
FINE AS WELL. SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
CRACKS AND MORE LIKE WE'RE ONLY
TALKING ABOUT EMERGENCY. IN THE
LAWS OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND DON'T
WORK. THE WAY IT SHOULD. WITH
THE THEY SHOULD- DURING AN
EMERGENCY- IT IT IS TO PROTECT
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF WE HAVE AN
EARTHQUAKE AND THERE'S AN AREA
THAT IS IN. NEED OF FOOD OR
OTHER KINDS OF. OF PRODUCTS- IT
IS BOTH. UNFAIR AND IMMORAL TO
COME IN AND MY VIEW. AND CHARGE
THOSE WHO ARE. AFFECTED
EXORBITANT PRICES WERE IN
ESSENCE YOU'RE BENEFITING YOUR
PROP FUNDING FOR THEIR- UP THIS
FOR. SO ONLY EMERGENCIES DOES
BY NUMBER TWO THE TEMPERS OF AS
THINK SO WINNER PER OUT IT IT
IS DRY OF FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT IT'S 10%
IT'S NOT 10% ABOVE YOUR COST
IT'S 10% ABOVE WHAT YOU WERE
CHARGING BEFORE SO THAT YOU
KNOW YOU THAT I SUPPOSE YOU CAN
INCREASE YOUR PRICES 9% AND BE
BE IN GOOD SHAPE. OF THAT'S OF
IT'S A FAIR TO FOR MARK UP IT'S
A FAIR PROFIT DOING PENSIVE
EMERGENCY- THE NOTHING REALLY
MAGICAL ABOUT 10% COULD BE 11%
COULD BE 9% BUT IT IT'S WHAT WE
THOUGHT WOULD BE SORT OF A FAIR
OF FAIR. IT'S AN IT IF YOU SO
FOR LET'S SAY YOU'RE SELLING
MEAT. AND THE COST TO YOU OF
MEAT HAS INCREASED AND YOU HAVE
TO INCREASE YOUR CALL YOUR YOUR
PRICE TO CONSUMERS. YOU'RE NOT
IN YOU'RE YOU'RE ONLY IN
VIOLATION WHERE. BASICALLY YOUR
COSTS AND TO SENATOR WINNERS
POINT WILL WILL TRY TO PUT IN
SIX COSTS AS WELL AS LABOR
COSTS- NOT INCREASE IN IN YOUR
JUST BENEFITING BASICALLY FROM
THE FROM THE EMERGENCY. OF MR
PAPA GEORGE SAY THE ONE THAT.
THROUGH CHIRLA GRANTED IF YOU
WANT TO ADD. FLEA MODERATOR IF
MISTER POPPE COURT GEORGE IS
STILL ON THE LINE HE CAN
BRIEFLY RESPOND IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME
AT THIS POINT YES. WE CAN YOU
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THE CENTER MARK
AND SENATOR WE ARE THOSE ARE
THE KINDS OF CONCERNS THAT WE
VERY MUCH ARE WILLING TO WORK
WITH. IT WAS THE SENATOR STE A
STAFF AND ORANGE COUNTY AND OUR
SANITY IS OFFICE AND I BELIEVE
WE CAN RESOLVE BOTH OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
DESCRIBED. FIRST AN EXPLANATION
OF HOW THE- RULE WORKS FOR
EXISTING SELLERS BECAUSE I
THINK IT. CAN RESOLVE SEVERAL
THESE CONCERNS. FOR AN EXISTING
SELLER SELLER PRIOR TO THE
EMERGENCY. THE CURRENT LAW. FOR
ME IT'S NOT ONLY THE 10%
INCREASE THAT'S ACTUALLY EIGHTY
AT THE END OF THE- THE
ARITHMETIC HERE THE CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS AN EXISTING BUSINESS. TO
INCREASE ITS PRICE. TO COVER
ANY INCREASED COSTS MATERIAL OF
THE LABOR AND THE LIKE. IT
ALLOWS THE BUSINESS TO ADD ITS
CURRENT PROFIT MARGIN. ON TOP
OF THOSE CHANGED COSTS THEN
ALLOWS AN ADDITIONAL 10% ABOVE
THAT SOME SOME OF THE INCREASED
COSTS PLUS THEIR TRADITIONAL
MARKUP SO CENTER WE'RE AM VERY
CONSCIOUS OF THE CONCERN THAT
YOU EXPRESSED AND I'M CONFIDENT
WE CAN WORK OUT LANGUAGE TO
MAKE THESE PRINCIPLES APPLY
BOTH THE NEW SELLERS. CAN TO
PRIOR SELLERS BUT BUT THE GOOD
NEWS IS- FOR EXISTING
BUSINESSES THEY ARE PROTECTED
THEY CAN INCREASE THEIR PRICES
TO COVER INCREASED COSTS THEY
CAN APPLY THEIR TRADITIONAL
PROFIT MARGIN. AND EVEN 10%
BEYOND THAT SO THERE'S PLENTY
OF SEATING AT IN MY JUDGMENT
DAN TO PROTECT EXISTING SELLERS
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
DO THE SAME KIND OF THING FOR
NEW SELLERS WE CHOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S- 50% ABOVE OSTS-
FORMULA BUT WE CAN ABSOLUTELY
INCORPORATE- THE ADDITIONAL
FACTORS THAT I JUST DESCRIBED
SO WE CAN. HAVE BOTH EXISTING
SELLERS NEW SO. EVERY
ADEQUATELY MAKING A REASONABLE
PROCESS BUT JUST NOT GOUGING
THE ONE DOLLAR GAG MASKS BEING
SOLD FOR TEN. THANK YOU MENTION.
PHONE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN
THE CENTER MORE LIKE I BEFORE.
YOU YOUR OF COMPLETED CENTER
WIENER BEFORE I GO BACK TO
SENATOR JACKSON HAD A COMMENT
AND THEN I CAN RETURN SO I A I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL- GIVEN THE NATURE OF
THIS YEAR- AND OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S STILL MORE WORK TO BE
DONE. I FIND PRODUCT PRICE
COUNTERS TO BE AMONG THE LOWEST
OF THE LOW- THIS ISN'T A
QUESTION OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND
THIS IS NOT A QUESTION OF
CHOICE. SUPPLY AND DEMAND I
THINK AGAIN A PROPERLY APPLIES
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE A CHOICE. IN A
PANDEMIC OR IN AN EMERGENCY
SUCH AS WHAT YOUR BILL TALKS
ABOUT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE. AND THE FACT THAT
OTHERS WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE. OF
PEOPLE'S MISFORTUNE IN THIS
FASHION. IS REALLY OFFENSIVE TO
ME SO I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE AND I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE AND I THINK. ANY
ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY SUFFERS-
IT ISN'T JUST THE POOR ALTHOUGH
I SUSPECT THE POOR SUFFER MORE
THAN MOST IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THEY HAVE NO CHOICE WHETHER OR
NOT TO BUY. A PRODUCT AND AN
OUTRAGEOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT-
SO I SEE THIS AS A AS- A VERY
IMPORTANT- STATEMENT AND POLICY
IN MORAL POSITION TO TAKE- TO
DISCOURAGE THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR. IN THE MOST
APPROPRIATE AND SIGNIFICANT WAY
WE CAN AND SO MY QUESTION IS
THIS. I'M ASSUMING MOST OF
THESE. COMPANIES THAT DO THIS
KIND OF A CHART DID CHARGE
EXCESSIVELY. OUR CORPORATIONS
SAID THAT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GO OUT AND BUY IN BULK AND THEN
CHARGE AND AN OUTRAGEOUS AMOUNT
OF MONEY WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
MASKS AS AN EXAMPLE. CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING SO GENERALLY- YOU
CAN'T PUT A CORPORATION IN
JAIL. UNFORTUNATELY DOES THIS.
LEGISLATION ALLOW FOR THE
PIERCING OF THE CORPORATE VEIL
OF THE CORPORATE VEIL SO THAT
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE THE
CEOS OF THE UPPER MANAGEMENT
THE PEOPLE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS WILL BE PERSONALLY
LIABLE AND SUBJECT TO
INCARCERATION OF NOT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO PUT A WHOLE LOT OF
MISDEMEANOR IN- IN JAIL BUT IF
THESE WERE CHARGED IS AS
FELONIES WOULD WE BE ABLE TO
THEN TAKE AND- CHARGER THESE.
INDIVIDUALS ARE FOR THE
BEHAVIOR OF THEIR COMPANIES SO
THAT THEY WOULD THEN HAVE MORE
TO LOSE THAN PERHAPS SOME SMALL
AMOUNT OF PROFIT FOR THE
COMPANY THAT THEY WOULD BE
INDIVIDUALLY LIABLE. BUT I HAD
SENATOR UMBERG AMIR SPINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATE JACKSON.
THIS DOES NOT CHANGE THE LAW IN
TERMS OF PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CORPORATE
ACTS SO IT WOULD BE. ANALOGOUS
TO THE ENRON SITUATION SO YOU
YOU CAN CHARGE BOTH THE
CORPORATION AS WELL AS THE
INDIVIDUAL IF YOU CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL. MET THE CRITERIA
FOR PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
EXAMPLE THEY WERE KNOWING. AND
A DATE THEY WERE BOTH KNOWING
AND HAD MADE THE DECISION TO
FOR EXAMPLE INCREASE PRICES SO.
WELL THIS BILL DOESN'T DOESN'T
CHANGE THE LAW INDIVIDUALS
COULD BE SUBJECT TO IT EVEN IF
IT'S- THEIR ACTING THROUGH A
CORPORATION. THAT MAKES SENSE
THE CENTER IS A I THINK SO BUT
I. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THAT PEOPLE NOT BE ABLE TO HIDE
BEHIND THAT CORPORATE FAIL WHEN
THEY CONDUCT THEMSELVES IN THIS
FASHION THE FACT THAT WE KNOW
THAT WE LOST SOME OF OUR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS BECAUSE THEY THE OF
THE UNAVAILABILITY OF THESE
MASS IN THE DESERT. DECISIONS
MADE TO CHARGE MORE TO MAKE
MONEY. A IS TO EXERCISE GREED
IN THE OF THE WORST ORDER.
DURING A TIME WHEN WE ARE ALL.
IT AT RISK AND ARE ALL
SUFFERING IN SOME FORM OR
ANOTHER FROM THE SUCH AS TO WHY
I HOPE THAT THAT IS PART OF
THIS AND- AGAIN- WITH YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS BILL I RECOGNIZE OUR
CONCERNS IN THEIR LEGITIMATE. I
WILL SUPPORT IT SO THAT THE
PROCESS CAN CONTINUE AT WITH
THAT OF COURSE SUBJECT TO THE
DECISION ON THE FLOOR BUT I BUT
I DO THANK YOU FOR BRING THIS
SITE I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
INFURIATING I FEEL. WHEN I SEE
THE CURRENT ASK PRICE GOUGING
WHETHER IT'S FOR WIPES- NOW
CHARGING TEN TIMES THE COST FOR
WIPE SO THAT WE CAN TRY TO
PROTECT OUR OUR HEALTH AND THE
HEALTH OF OUR- FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITY. THE NOTION THAT WE
WILL ALLOW THE TO OUR UNWILLING
TO- TAKE SOME KIND OF-
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE- THE
GENERAL WELL BEING- I SHOULD.
FIND IT TO BE JUST ACCEPTABLE
THANK YOU. CENTER OR DID YOU
HAVE A GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU
I THINK EVERYONE AGREES HERE.
PRICE GOUGING A STRONG COUPLE
CONCERNS I HAVE THAT I THAT I
LIKE TO ASK- IS CURRENT LAW I
UNDERSTAND SAYS THAT- THINGS
WILL BE RESTATED WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS BUT THERE'S NO TIME FRAME
ON YOUR BILL. AND THEN AM I
RIGHT THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR WOULD DECIDE WHAT
AN EMERGENCY IS AND HOW LONG
THE TIME FRAMES TO GO. IT IT IT
IS TRUE IT'S DURING THE
PENDENCY RUMORED SURPLUS THIRTY
DAYS SO AS IS THE CLERK BY THE
GOVERNOR THAT THAT'S CORRECT.
SO THERE THERE'S NOT SO. IT IS.
DISCRETIONARY FOR EXAMPLE ON
THE PART OF THE GOVERNOR IS THE
HOW LONG THAT EMERGENCY. SHOULD
STILL BE IMPACTING CALIFORNIA
HAD A BAD GOVERNOR NOT THAT OUR
GOVERNOR IS NOW WE GOT A BAD
GOVERNOR MY SIDE OUT. THEY
COULD USE THAT TO WEAPONIZE
BUSINESSES CUT NAY. THEY COULD-
I'LL I WOULD HOPE THAT THE- IF
WE HAVE A BAD GOVERNOR WE WOULD
NOT HAVE A BAD LEGISLATURE AND
THAT THAT THEY COULD ACT. TO
SEIZE THE EMERGENCY. I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU HOPE APPLE
WOULDN'T BE BETTER TO CLEARLY
STATED IN YOUR BILL. BUT TO
STATE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
OVERRIDE THE GOVERNOR NO TO
STATE THAT THERE'D BE A TIME
FRAME ON THESE THINGS. IN THE
CURRENT EXACTLY YOU KNOW
SPECIFICATIONS ON THE TYPES OF
EMERGENCIES. SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A GOVERNOR THAT. AND
RECLAIM SOME SUBMERGENCE SEE
ONE IT'S REALLY NOT BELT BUT I
THINK THAT. I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN OF. THE THERE IS A LAW
THAT DEFINES WHEN AN EMERGENCY
COULD BE DECLARED IN AND I
RECALL CORRECTLY UNDER WHAT
CONDITIONS IT CAN CONTINUE THIS
BILL DOESN'T. THE ONLY AS MY
UNDERSTANDING YOU KNOW MY
DAUGHTER AND WE CAN ASK THE
CONSULTANT TO CORRECT IF EITHER
OF US ARE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
STATUTE WHICH DEFINES WHAT CAN
BE A STATE OF EMERGENCY IN THE
ONLY. THING THAT THIS BILL DOES
RELATIONSHIP TO THAT IS ADD
PANDEMIC BECAUSE PANDEMIC WAS
NOT IN THE ORIGINAL STATUTE.
AND THE ADDITIONAL- ACTION THAT
THIS BILL IS DOING IS BECAUSE
THE BECAUSE THE ORIGINAL PRICE
GOUGING STATUTE IS ONLY OP. THE
TIMES OF EMERGENCY. THIS IS
MODIFYING THE PRICE GOUGING
STATUTE TO- WITH THE IN WITH
HIS ACCEPTING OF THE AMENDMENTS
TO. ALLOW IT TO BE A WAFFLER.
AND AS I INDICATED PREVIOUSLY
ADDING PANDEMIC AS A CATEGORY
OF EMERGENCY. DID AYE ASK
ACCURATELY PORTRAY THAT. THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT KIT IS
NODDING SHE CAN ACTUALLY SPEAK
INTO THE MIKE. YES THAT'S A
CORRECT SUMMARY OKAY IT DOESN'T
CHANGE THE DEFINITION OR HOW
YOU DECLARE. A STATE THAT'S
WHAT A STATE OF EMERGENCY YEARS
OR HOW THAT IN THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY ITSELF WHILE IN THE
GOVERNOR THE CLERK IT. YOUR THE
GOVERNOR AND HAVE BUT IN EIGHT
ANY IN THE DECLARATION OF A
DOES NOT HAVE TO PUT AN END
DATE ON IT YOU'RE RIGHT. BUT
IT- SO I SUPPOSE IN FOR THE
CIRCUMSTANCE YOU'RE DESCRIBING.
THERE COULD BE A GOVERNOR WHO
DECLARE STATE EMERGENCY AND
NEVER LEFT SET- SO THAT THAT'S
WHERE THERE COULD BE. LET'S
SEE- YOUR CONCERN WOULD MIGHT
APPLY BUT I DON'T WELL WE CAN
NEVER YOU DON'T KNOW SO ANYWAY
AN AUTHOR I DON'T KNOW IF YOU.
WELL I THINK THAT ONE AT ALL
THE ONLY CHECK WELL I DON'T OF
THE ONLY CHECK BUT EIGHT CHECK
ON A GOVERNOR WHO DECIDES THAT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY IN
PERPETUITY. IS LEGISLATURE
ENACTED LEGISLATION THAT ENDS
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY. SO IF
WE HAVE A LEGISLATURE AND WE
HAVE A GOVERNOR. THAT BOTH ACT
BASICALLY DO EFFECT PRICE
CONTROLS FOR EVER. I DON'T I
SUPPOSE INITIATIVE IS THE NEXT
NEXT FALL BACK BUT. CENTER
RURAL YOU MAY CONTINUE A FEW.
OUR. I THINK A WHOLE LOT VOTING
ON THIS UNTIL. THE PROPER
LANGUAGES INSERTED IN BILL I
THANK YOU CENTER. RIGHT ARMS D.
SO LET ME- MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS OH SORRY SENATOR MORE
LIKE- IT JUST A QUICK QUESTION-
ANTICIPATING WHAT WHAT I MAY BE
ASKED BY CONSTITUENTS AND- SO.
WE'RE KEEPING THIS PRETTY
CONTEMPORARY WITH FACE MASKS
AND- SWIPE SAID BUT THE BIG
ISSUES BEEN TOILET PAPER. AND
SO YOU KNOW MY WIFE COMMENTS
OFTEN VOIGTS STILL BUT THE YOU
KNOW THE SHELVES ARE STILL
EMPTY SO SOMEONE IS BUYING
TOILET PAPER AT RETAIL. AND
THEN- WE'RE GETTING REPORTS OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND SELLING
IT THEMSELVES SOME MORALES. AND
THEN THERE FOR PRICE CAPTION
MAKING. OPPORTUNITY OUT OF- AS
SENATE JACKSON SAID WERE WERE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
INSIDE. I I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW
WITH THE D. A.'S RESOLVE. THAT
SECOND TRANSACTION AND I ASK IT
JUST SO THAT I CAN BE PREPARED
TO RESPOND. AHEAD THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I THINK IF YOU
BOUGHT TOILET PAPER AND YOU'RE
NOW IN THE BUSINESS OF SELLING
RETAIL TOILET PAPER AND YOU BUY
IT FOR. A DOLLAR AND YOU SELL
IT FOR TEN DOLLARS YES I THINK
YOU WOULD BE IN VIOLATION OF
THIS BILL- IF IT SHOULD BE
ENACTED. THANK YOU CENTER BURKE
THANK YOU MANAGER. SENATOR
WIENER I THANK YOU ROGER I JUST
WHEN I HAVE A- GIVEN THAT THE
CLARITY OF YOU'RE GOING TO WORK
WITH US I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THE
BILL TODAY- IT'S A I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF IMPORTANT
STUFF IN HERE SO I'M HAPPY TO.
VOTE FOR. THANK YOU SIR. ALL
RIGHT SO BEFORE I ASK YOU TO
CLOSE I CAN OF COURSE SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WANTS
COMMON- MORE QUESTION FIVE. THE
ORIGINAL BILL HAD BOTH THE
LOBULAR AND A SEARCH WARRANT
FOR MISDEMEANORS. NOW WE- I
LOOK I THINK ALL OF US WELL LET
ME SPEAK FOR MYSELF SO I DO
REALLY BELIEVE IN CONSUMER
PROTECTION ESPECIALLY DURING.
THIS KIND OF AN EMERGENCY WHERE
PEOPLE DO TRY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF. AND BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT SO
IT IS EIGHTY WHETHER IT'S A BIG
CORPORATION THAT DOES IT OR
YOUR CORNER STORE IS JUST AS
BAD TO THE CONSUMER TO CONSUMER
DOESN'T CARE. HOWEVER THERE'S
SOME PERCEPTION BY CONSUMERS
THAT THE CORNER STORE WHO
SELLING SAY AN ITEM FOR MUCH
MORE THEN YOU'D BUY IT AT
COSTCO OR TARGET THAT SOMEHOW
THAT MEANS IT'S PRICE GOUGING.
AND THE CONSUMERS NOT REALIZING
THAT KNOW THAT SMALL STORE
COULD IT BY IN THEIR HAVING NO
THEIR **** SUPPLY CHAIN IS
ALSO- WHATEVER LIMITED THEY
DON'T BUY IN THE BOOK THAT THE
TARGETS OF THE COST GOES. DíAS
THEY REALLY HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO SELL IT AT THAT HIGH PRICE
AT LEAST THEY'RE MAKING IT
AVAILABLE TO YOU. SO IT THIS IS
ONE OF THESE AND THREADING THE
NEEDLE. WELL I DO NOT WANT ANY
STORE PRICE GOUGING ANYONE I
ALSO DON'T WANT TO LOOK HAVE A
FISHING EXPEDITION WHAT BECAUSE-
YOU. A CORNER STORE THAT IS
SELLING SOMETHING AT A HIGH
PRICE WHICH MADE MAYBE REALLY
THEY HAVE NO CHOICE. AND A
PROSECUTOR WANTS TO YOU KNOW
GET A HEADLINE OF. THE WIND SEE
WE'VE YOU KNOW DON'T. WITH
PRICE GOUGING HERE. AND THEN IS
YOU KNOW IT MIGHT OTHERWISE BE
MISDEMEANOR DATE THAT WE GIVE
THEM THE ABILITY TO GO GET A
SEARCH WARRANT AND OF COURSE
THE SEARCH WARRANT IN AND OF
ITSELF. IS VERY DISRUPTIVE TO A
TO A BUSINESS OR TWO AND
COSTLY. SO NOW A WAFFLER. I
DON'T LIKE RARE IF ANYBODY WHO
WATCHES THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS
THAT WE RARELY EVER INCREASE
THE PENALTY YOUR IT OR- TURN A
CRIME THAT IS OTHER WHAT
MISDEMEANOR AND FELONY. WE TRY
TO AVOID. BUT I THINK WE AND
JUST FOR THE MEMBERS TO KNOW
THERE WAS A LOT OF A THERE WAS
A LOT OF DISCUSSION ON THIS
BILL THERE WAS A LOT OF BACK
AND FORTH MICE THE STAFF AND
THE COMMITTEE WORKED I THINK
REALLY- DID JUST REALLY
DILIGENTLY AND LOT OF GREAT
INTERACTION WITH SENATOR UMBERG
IN HIS STAFF TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT OKAY. HOW DO WE OUR
OBJECTIVE IN THE COMMITTEES
OBJECTIVE WAS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS BUT NOT JUST JUST-
YOU KNOW CREATE THIS BIG NET
FOR BIG FISHING EXPEDITIONS AND
SO WE ENDED WITH SENATOR
UMBERG'S. AGREEMENT THOUGH I
WILL SAY THE AUTHOR WOULD
PREFER THE SEARCH WARRANT BUT
THAT'S OKAY TO GO WAFFLER
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS FOR THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE THE DA CAN
PROVE TO THE COURT OR
DEMONSTRATE TO THE COURT THAT
THEY REALLY THINK THIS
SITUATION IS EGREGIOUS THAT
THEY CAN GET THE SEARCH
WARRANT. AND SPREAD IT DOESN'T
JUST AUTOMATICALLY GRANT THE
SEARCH WARRANT FOR SOMETHING
THAT IS A MIST MISDEMEANORS
THAT'S WHAT I WE WENT WITH THE
DIRECTION WE WENT I IMAGINE I'M
SURE THERE'S SOME. THE. WHO
WHATEVER LIKE TO RETURN. THAT
FEEL THAT EVEN ALONE IS. TWO
FOUR. BUT I AM COME IN. IT
BECAUSE IT IS A LIMITED TERM
PRICE GOUGING ONLY APPLIES
DURING THESE EMERGENCIES. AND
SO THAT IS THAT LOGIC AND THAT
IS WHY I AM SUPPORTING THE
AMENDMENT THAT'S WHY I'M A AND
THE BILL. AND APPRECIATIVE OF
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
MINUTE. AND WITH THAT I'LL SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OTHERWISE YOU MAY CLOSE. AS
THEY CAN AND YOU'RE JUST A
COUPLE QUICK COMMENTS WILL WE
WILL GO DOWN THE SEARCH WARRANT
HOLD BUT- IT SEARCH WARRANTS
ARE CRITICAL IN A WHITE COLLAR
CASE LIKE PRICE GOUGING BECAUSE
YOU YOU YOU CAN'T PROVE. WHAT
THE PROFIT MARGIN IS WITHOUT
GETTING THE UNDERLYING
DOCUMENTS FOR THE MOST PART AND
IN SOME COMMUNITIES OF FOR
EXAMPLE MY OWN DISTRICT PEOPLE-
WILL REPORT THAT THERE'S BEEN
PRICE GOUGING BUT THE RELUCTANT
TO COME FORWARD YOU KNOW
PERHAPS BECAUSE OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS OR WHAT HAVE YOU BUT THE
RELUCTANT TO COME FORWARD TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT THEIR LOCAL.
STORE TO SENATOR JACKSON'S
POINT ABOUT. HAVING A FELONY
AVAILABLE I BELIEVE THAT THAT
IS CRITICAL IT IS CRITICAL TO
TURN THE LARGER ENTITIES FROM
GAUGING IN PRICE GOUGING AND
YOU'RE RIGHT SENATOR- SKINNER
THE PEOPLE MAY THINK THAT. YOU
GO TO X. Y. Z. STORE AND YOU
SEE THE PRICE MARKED UP IT MUST
BE LEGITIMATE BECAUSE WHY WOULD
X. Y. Z. STORE INCREASE PRICES
TEN FOLD OF BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT THEY'RE- CREDIBLE
OPERATORS BUT SOME DO. AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF FELONY DOES A
COUPLE THINGS ONE IT SHOULD
INTIMIDATE FOLKS UNDERPLAYING
PRICE GOUGING BUT- IT YOU TRY
TO. MONEY IN EUROPE TO ENTITY
YOUR- THIS YOU STOCK PRICES GO
TO TUMBLE IN THAT A- TO. I
THANK TO AT LEAST SOME ENTITIES
ANYWAY SO THAT THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BILL-
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER WEEK
WE SPENT THE- ZERO AMOUNT OF
TIME WORKING ON THIS STAFF.
WORKED VERY HARD AND DILIGENTLY
AND APPRECIATE MERGE NOVEL. ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT IS THERE A
MOTION. FOR A NEW BILLS MOVED
AND- WE WILL GO THE BILL THE
MOTION IS. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED OKAY-
DO PASSES MEDI TO
APPROPRIATIONS GO AHEAD ROLL
CALL DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER BY IN
OUR AYE MORLOCK. MOORLACH AYE
BRADFORD. JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE
MORALE. WIENER WIENER HI. FIVE
ZERO. ON THE BILL'S FIVE ZERO
IT IS OUT AND- THANK YOU AND-
SENATOR UMBERG ON BEFORE YOU.
PICK UP YOUR NEXT BILL I JUST
WANT TO- A ASK THE COMMITTEE'S
INDULGENCE FOR A MOMENT I-
SENATOR HER TITLE AN APOLOGY
BECAUSE I- THOUGHT THAT GIVEN
THE CALENDAR THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE A NOTHER HEARING SCHEDULED
THAT WE COULD NOT GRANT
RECONSIDERATION BUT ACTUALLY WE
CAN IF WE DO WE CHOOSE TO
ALWAYS GRANT RECONSIDERATION
THAT IS MY BAD IT WAS MY
MISTAKE AND OF COURSE. WE KNOW
THAT THE CALENDARS DO THIS YEAR
THE CALENDAR OF WE MAY END UP
HAVING ANOTHER HEARING CHAU I
WANT TO A WITH THE- COMMITTEES
A SUPPORT- GRANT
RECONSIDERATION TO SENATOR
FURTADO'S BILL AND APOLOGIZE TO
HER THAT I MADE THAT ERROR SO
WITH THAT WE'VE GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION TO OUR BILL AND
NOW WE WILL GO BACK TO SENATOR
UMBERG AND WE WILL START WITH
THE HEARING ON SB TWELVE
TWENTY. THE YOUR NEXT BILL GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF WHAT ONCE AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN PARTICULAR GAVE
BECAUSE WELL THE THIS IS A
CHALLENGING ISSUE. THAT HAS
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVES I SUPPOSE I
SHOULD TAKE PRIDE IN THE FACT
THAT I HAVE UNITED THE ACLU
PUBLIC DEFENDERS OF SOME RANK
AND FILE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND C.
H. P. ALL TO TAKE THE SAME
POSITION. SADLY IT'S OPPOSING
THE BILL- BUT WHAT BUT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IT IS
THAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE A FAIR MECHANISM THAT
ADDRESSES THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS AND ADDRESSES THE
CONCERNS OF. FAIRNESS IN IN
MAKING SURE THAT DEFENDANTS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
INFORMATION THAT MAY BE
CRITICAL FOR THEM IN THE
DEFENSE OF THEIR CASE BUT IS
ALSO FAIR LAW ENFORCEMENT ALL
THOSE AND PROVIDES FOR THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S A MECHANISM
SO THAT THEY CAN COMPLY WITH
THE CONSTITUTION REQUIREMENTS
THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION- ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY. WHO IS GOING TO
TESTIFY I BELIEVE ON THE BILL
AS WELL AS A MENTOR COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY GREG TOTTEN
AND OTHERS CLING THEIR MORRIS
OF WORKED EXTREMELY HARD ON THE
BILL- IT AS YOU KNOW- THE BRADY
DECISION REQUIRES THAT OF
EVIDENCE MITIGATE SIR IS THIS
CALL THE TORY BE PROVIDED TO-
DEFENDANTS SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY
DEFEND THEMSELVES. OF ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES AND WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS IS IF THERE IS A%
WITNESS THAT IT IS KNOWN TO
HAVE- A POTENTIAL TO HAVE
CERTAIN INFORMATION THAT MIGHT
BE USED IN CROSS EXAMINATION IT
IS THAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY AT LEAST FOR
DEFENSE COUNSEL TO. EXPLORE
THAT THAT ISSUE AND IN ORDER TO
DO SO A LOT THIS CREATED IT'S
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE
BRADY LIST- THIS LAW THIS
DECISION'S BEEN AFFECT FOR MANY
MANY YEARS. WELL AS LONG FOR
BERMAN AND THESE ARE OUR CA.
THE THERE'S ISSUE IS TO AT DUTY.
THERE ARE SOME THAT FOR
WHATEVER REASON ARE ARE HAVING
A CHALLENGE IN COMPLYING AND
WHAT THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO DO
IS TO CREATE A STATEWIDE
STANDARD. A STATEWIDE STANDARD
AS TO WHAT MUST BE- WENT WHEN
AN OFFICER- HAS THIS ISSUE IN
HIS OR HER. PAST THAT THAT WHAT
ISSUES ARE REQUIRED BASICALLY
TO- PLACE SOMEONE ON THE BRADY
LIST. AND THEN ALSO- AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IF THEY ARE. IF THEY
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE UNFAIRLY
PLACED ON THE LIST THAT THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME
SORT OF REVIEW. SO THAT THEY
CAN GET OFF THE LIST I'VE
HEARD- A SERIES OF STORIES OF
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN PLACED ON THE
READY LISTS THAT AT LEAST IN MY
VIEW SHOULD BE ON THE BRACELET
SO FOR EXAMPLE AN OFFICER THAT
HAD A- MISDEMEANOR VANDALISM
CONVICTION FROM SEVERAL YEARS
AGO. THAT DOESN'T REALLY IMPACT
THAT OFFICES CREDIBILITY BUT
BEING ON THE BRADY LIST HAS A-
VERY- THE- DETRIMENTAL IMPACT
ON OFFICERS CAREER. SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT
ESTABLISHES BOTH- THE STANDARD
A STANDARD FOR BEING PUT ON THE
BRADY LIST OF STANDARD FOR
BEING THE AT LEAST REVIEW. SO
THAT OFFICER IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE SOME SORT OF DUE
PROCESS. WITH ME OR AT LEAST ON
THE PHONE WE HAVE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY AND
THIS ATTORNEY GREG TOTTEN- I'LL
TURN OVER THEM MADAM CHAIR. YES
MODERATOR YOU CAN ALLOW THEM
AND A APOLOGIES- WITNESSES KEY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOUR TOTAL
TIME TO SHARE BETWEEN YOU IS
THREE MINUTES THANK YOU. AN
ADVISER OPEN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS NANCY
O'MALLEY THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY I'M ALSO THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF CD A AND
I'M HERE TO A TEST CITED THE
IMPORTANCE OF SB TWELVE TWENTY.
STILL ENHANCES THE EXISTING
STATUTORY AND CASE LAW FROM
BOTH THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT. SP
TWELVE SP TWELVE TWENTY DOES
NOT DISTURB STATUTORY
PROTECTIONS OF CONFIDENTIALITY
OVER PERSONAL RECORDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. IT DOES
HOWEVER BALANCE IN PRIORITIZE A
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS OF
AN ACCUSED INDIVIDUAL IN A
CRIMINAL PROCEEDING. IT IS THAT
IMPORTANT BALANCE THE
PROSECUTORS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
VALUE. AND UNDER WHICH WE MUST
OPERATE AS PROSECUTORS WE SEEK
JUSTICE NOT SADLY CONVICTIONS.
AS PROSECUTORS AT THE CORE OF
OUR PROFESSIONALISM AND ETHICAL
STANDARDS WE MUST PROVIDE THE
DEFENSE WITH ANY AND ALL
EVIDENCE IT MAY EXONERATED
DEFENDANT INCLUDING EVIDENCE
RELEVANT TO THE MORAL TURPITUDE
AND HONESTY OF A PARTICULAR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. HIS TESTIMONY IS
MATERIAL TO THE GUILT OR
INNOCENCE OF THE ACCUSED. THIS
IS DECLARED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE BY THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT AND BRADY VERSUS
MARYLAND. AND WE HAVE FOLLOWED
THIS LEGAL TENNIS AT BRADY FOR
MORE THAN SIXTY YEARS. IN FACT
THIS DELICATE BALANCE BETWEEN
THE PROSECUTORS CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATIONS AND THE STATUTORY
PROTECTIONS A POLICE OFFICER
RECORDS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
EXISTED IN MANY COUNTIES SUCH
AS ALAMEDA COUNTY LOS ANGELES
VENTURA SAN MATTEO AND MANY
MORE CROSS THE STATE. WE HAVE
WRITTEN POLICIES AND PRACTICES
CREATED WITH OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS AN
ATTORNEY TO REPRESENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. IT
ENSURES COMPLETED COMPLIANCE
WHILE RESPECTING THE LAWS
PERTAINING TO PLEASE PERSONNEL
RECORDS. BUT THESE WORKING
POLICIES HAVE NOT BEEN
UNIVERSALLY ENACTED ACROSS ALL
COUNTIES ARE BY ALL AGENCIES.
AND THESE WORKING POLICIES HAVE
ALSO BEEN CHALLENGED IN COURT.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN IN THE CASE
ASSOCIATION FOR A LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFF'S VERSUS
SUPERIOR COURT THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT UNANIMOUSLY
DECLARED. THAT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY DOES NOT
VIOLATE THOSE POLICE OFFICER
RECORD PROTECTIONS BY PROVIDING
THE NAMES AND BADGE NUMBERS OF
OFFICERS WHO MAY HAVE
INFORMATION IN HIS OR HER
PERSONAL RECORD. THAT WOULD
FALL UNDER BRADY. TO BE CLEAR
SB TWELVE TWENTY DOES NOT
DISTURB THE CURRENT MANDATE AND
PROTECTIONS OF RECORDS. RATHER
IT REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY TO PROVIDE TO THE
PROSECUTION THE NAME AND BADGE
NUMBER OF AN OFFICER WHO MAY
HAVE INFORMATION IN HIS OR HER
PERSONAL RECORD. THE TRIGGER
FOR THE COURTS REVIEW OF A
PERSONAL RECORD IS NOT AN
ALLEGATION OR INVESTING FOR
THAT AN INVESTIGATION IS BEGAN.
THE TRIGGERS OF FINDING MADE
AGAINST THE OFFICER BARBIE-
TOOK. RETURN DISHONESTY OR THAT
THERE'S TERE WELL GROUNDED IN
THE LOCK. IF THAT OFFICER
BECOMES A WITNESS IN A CRIMINAL
CASE THE PROSECUTOR CAN EITHER
PROVIDE THE NAME AND BADGE
NUMBER TO THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY
OR FILE A MOTION WITH THE COURT
IS IT. H. REFUSED. TO FILE AN-
DEFINING SIX. NOT THERE'S ONLY
MINUTE LEFT. THANK IT'S SO
JUDGE PROVIDE ONLY THE RECORDS
BOAST AND MORE ACROSS CERTAINLY
THE DEFENSE AND ALL OF SOCIETY
MUST BE ABLE TO RELY ON THE
INTEGRITY OF THE CONVICTION SB
TWELVE TWENTY ALLOWS THAT
RELATES TO BE GROUNDED IN SOUND
POLICY THAT ADDRESSES THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS OF POLICE
OFFICERS BUT THE OVER ARCHING
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION OF
THE PROSECUTION TO ENSURE A
FAIR TRIAL FOR THE DEFENDANT. I
VOTE THANK YOU THE EIGHT TOP WE
NOW HAVE THIRTY SECONDS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FIRST ISSUE I
ONLY HAVE TWO POINTS FIRST. AS
PROSECUTORS WE FIND OURSELVES
FACING AN INSOLUBLE PROBLEM. WE
ARE COMPELLED BY THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE HIGHEST
COURT IN THE LAND TO DISCOVER
TO THE DEFENSE ALL EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE. YEAH THE SAME TIME
WE'RE HAMSTRUNG BY OUR LACK OF
ACCESS TO THE VERY INFORMATION
WE ARE DUTY BROWN TO PROVIDE.
SADLY WE CAN'T DISCOVER WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO OR EVEN
KNOW ABOUT. SECOND A RESPECTED
PEACE OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS AND
DEFENSE AND CIVIL LIBERTY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE OPPOSING
THIS BILL. AND STAND READY TO
WORK WITH THEM GOING FORWARD.
BUT AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS INTRACTABLE
ISSUE FOR MORE THAN TWO DECADES
I CURRENTLY BELIEVE CENTER ON
BURKE PROPOSAL STRIKES A
NECESSARY TIMELY AND DELICATE
BALANCE BETWEEN THEIR COMPETING
INTERESTS. NOW GONE OVER BY
TWENTY SECONDS SO- IF I WILL
ALLOW THE OPPOSITION THE EXTRA
TIME ADDITION SO. THANK YOU AT
ITS CORE THIS BILL YOU IT AND
YOU CANNOT SPEAK ANYMORE OR I
WILL HAVE TO KNOW THANK YOU SIR
SORRY. I JUST NEED TO BE FAIR
BECAUSE THE RULES WERE SET UP
THAT WAY AND OTHERWISE. I DON'T
MEAN TO CUT ANYONE OFF SO MY
APOLOGIES BUT I HAVE TO BE FAIR.
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU FOR. ALL
RIGHT SO. WE ARE NOW GOING TO
THE OTHER. CALLERS ON THE LINE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THE MODERATOR WILL INDICATE DID
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AND YOU'LL
GET TO INDICATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR SUPPORT.
SO MODERATOR PLEASE- GIVE THAT
INSTRUCTION TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ALSO WANT TO ADD IN IN THEIR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO TO GET
YOUR LINE NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AND THE OPERATOR
WILL GET TO YOUR YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN THE MEANTIME IS THERE
ANYONE PHYSICALLY IN THIS
HEARING ROOM. WHO IS. GOING TO
ADD TO THEIR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE OTHER OF A- SCENE
NINE GO AHEAD MODERATOR. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE OH
FIVE AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
I'M HEARING NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE TO LINE ONE OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M OPPOSITION.
SO WILL HOLD ELECTIONS YOU SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE OH FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M HERE NO
RESPONSE WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CA MARTEL CAUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE
KNOW OTHERS IN CUBA ONCE AGAIN
ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT. AND ALLOW
IN A FEW MOMENTS I'M HERE WE
KNOW OTHER THING QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL HEAR
FROM THAT. COMMITTEE TELL BED
FROM- POOR ACT AND THEN FROM
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON OF
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND IN TOTAL
YOU ALL HAVE THREE MINUTES AND
TWENTY SECONDS. GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GOING TO GET HELD ON BEHALF OF
PORAC CORRECT RESPECTFULLY
CLOSES AT TWELVE TWENTY AS
PRESENTED TO PORAC SB TWELVE
TWENTY IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WITH A WAY
TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL BRADY
INFORMATION IN THE PERSONNEL
FILES OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS EMPLOYED BY STATE WIDE
AGENCIES THE WORKING DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND MOVE AROUND THE
STATE. JACK WAS TOLD TO DO
ATTORNEY SPACED. IDENTIFIED
GRADIENT FROM FOR SUCH A LONG
OFF. WHICH PERSONNEL FILE
JERMAINE IN SO. IRAQ RECOGNIZES
THE OF PROSECUTING AGENCY TO
ALERT DEFENDANTS TO GRADIENT.
CORRECT BELIEVES TWO TWENTY GO
TO FOR IN THE TO ADDRESS THE
NARROW ISSUE GIVE RISE TO THE
PROPOSED I JUST. CORRECT COULD
HOWEVER SOME APPROACH LEAD YOU
IS A STATE GRADY LISTING. AND
PROCESS IT RECOGNIZED THE DUTY
ACROSS THE A- WHAT PROTECTING
THE AND WE INTERESTS OF A
PORTION OFFICER WITH YOUR TO
BRADY LIST. SUCH WOULD MEAN TO
INCLUDE PROVISIONS FOR NOTE
OFFICE OF THEIR POTENTIAL PLACE
ON BRADY MISTER THEIR ARE AT.
PROVIDING A WITH ME OP TO
PREVENT THE IMP OR ARBITRARY OF
THEIR NAMES TO BRADY PRESS. WE
NOTIFY OFFICERS WHENEVER THEIR
NAMES ARE ACTUALLY ADDED TO
BRADY LIST ALONG WITH THE
REASONS FOR DOING SO DOING SO.
ALLOWING OFFICERS TO SEEK
REMOVAL OF THEIR NAMES BASED ON
CHANGED CIRCUMSTANCES WITHOUT
SUCH PROVISIONS KORAK CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT A LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON. GOOD MORNING LUCKILY
CALLED WAS USED IN CALIFORNIA
DEFENDERS WITH BERKELEY IS
WHERE I'VE BEEN JOINING A LOT
FOR SOME MERGED I HOWEVER OUR
RESULTS ARE QUITE OPPOSITE TO
LINE FORCING. THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL WE'RE GOING THE TYPE
OF THEM FROM TO JUST TO NOW IT
CHAU NAY WAS FAILED JIMMY TO
COME TO RIGHT. OF BEING MEROLA
THE LANGUAGE OF THE LANGUAGE IN
THE U. S. RETURNING MANUAL
WE'RE NOTICED BY LINE ACROSS
THE- OF ALL I IMPLE MUST. EVEN
IF NOT JUST. HOW TO FIND A
NOTICE TO THE- ANY IN ALSO A
PROBLEM. MANY IF NOT MOST
PROSECUTORS. ALL KNOW THE
OFFICE. HOWEVER THIS LEAD
SOMETIMES TO THE DOWN BULL AND.
IN IN NOT A HIS OR HER IN. TO
THE BOARD LESS WE HAVE SUC.
OUT OF LAST CAN. IN IN DEATH
METAL CASE. IT THIS WAS JUST.
QUITE BY A- AND BECAUSE GRAY
PROBLEM FOR THE- INDEPTH HELP
YOU. FOR THE REASONS WE WORSE
REQUEST YOUR NO BOAT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL NOW. GO TO OF A
AND THAT WAS UNDER THREE
MINUTES ANYWAY WE WILL NOW GO
TO. THE PUBLIC COLORS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO ONE WHO CAME INTO
THIS ROOM AND I KNOW THERE'S NO
ONE WHO WENT INTO ROOM TWO SO
WE HAVE NO FOR. A SECOND FLOOR
CONFERENCE ROOM SORRY SO WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S NOT
PHYSICALLY ANYONE- HERE THAT
WANTS TESTIFY SO WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE AND MODERATOR IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO HAS CALLED
IN. IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
YOU CAN- RECOGNIZE THEIR LINE
AND THEY CAN INDICATE THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND THAT THEY
OPPOSE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND
IF YOU DID NOT GIVE YOUR NAME
TO THE OPERATOR PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO TO GET A LINE NUMBER
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A LINE
NUMBER ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. YOU GET A LINE
NUMBER. AND IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT. AND WE WILL GO. LINE
ONE- FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND IT'S QUITE A SMILE
ON BEHALF OF THE OF CALIFORNIA
REGRETFUL OPPOSITION- SIMPLY
WANT TO SAY WE THANK AUTHOR AND
STAFF COMMERCE REGARDING A
CONCERN ARE CONSIDERING A
PROPOSAL. THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU GO TO LINE. ONE FIVE.
DAN AYKROYD AMMO THE HAVE THE
SAME FRANCISCO DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU GO TO
LINE. NINETY YOU MENTIONED THE
RUNNING SHERMAN RIVERSIDE SHARE
STATION ALSO OFFICER. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE. FOR THE
ALLUSION THE LOCK THEIR POLICE
ACOSTA LEAGUE IN THE CRITICAL
CALLED SO. IN OPPOSITE. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE OH EIGHT. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ERIN RE READ CAL
SOCIAL OF HIGH COME WE ONE
IDENTIFY WITH MISS TALBOTT
TESTIMONY WE OPPOSED AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR IS TO
OUR ARGUMENTS ARE A OF YOUR IN
OUR- THANK YOU. WE KNOW THERE'S
A Q. THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT LET'S
PUT THE LAW PHONE NUMBER BACK
ON SCREEN SO JUST BECAUSE WE
KNOW THERE BEEN THESE ISSUES
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT ANYONE
IS TO CALL YOU IN OUR- OR- IS
THE TO BE. SO AGAIN NOW LINE IS
A FOUR THIS IS LAW YOU CALL A
284-421-6364 AN ACCESS CODE.
SIX TWO TWO SIX FIVE FIVE
EIGHT. SO OUR MODERATOR IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN. THAT
YOU CAN. TELL THEM HOW DO YOU
SIGNAL YOU AND I WOULD ALLOW
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT
THIS POINT JUST BECAUSE- IT'S
HARD TO. FOLLOW ALL THE SO GO
HEAD MODERATOR. THANK YOU AND
TELL IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO TO GET
YOUR LINE NUMBER IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THAT. ONE AND THEN ZERO
AND THAT WILL PLACE YOU IN CUE.
THE ONCE AGAIN ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AND I AM SHOWING NO NEW LINES
HE WOULD UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT. OKAY I'M A WHICH TO
PROBE FOR US TO GIVEN THAT. DO
WE THIS IS SO I. TO JUST GIVE
THE WHOEVER TO THE ABILITY TO
DO SO NO ONE FEELS WE RUSHED
NOW MEMBERS ARE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL. THREE OF MY FAVORITE DJS
ARI SUPPORT THE CHOICE DUDLEY
FROM SANTA BARBARA WHO ACTUALLY
DURING LAW SCHOOL WORK FOR ME
SO I CAN ATTEST TO HER A
COMMITMENT TO JUSTICE- I
APPRECIATE THE HER CONCERN AND
CERTAINLY A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TAWTON WHO HAS HAD A
COMMENDABLE CAREER- INVENTOR
COUNTY AND OF COURSE. MS
O'MALLEY WHO IS ONE OF MY SHE
AS WELL TAKING A POSITION I
THINK THIS BILL DOES BACK. OF
THE CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS- ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I ASKED WHEN I
WAS LOOKING AT THIS IS- IT DOES
INDICATE THE BILL SCOPE OF
DISCLOSURE WOULD INCLUDE
OFFICERS IN THE FOLLOWING
CIRCUMSTANCES AND AMONG THEM
ARE SUSTAIN FINDINGS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT. A SUSTAINED FINDINGS
OF DISHONESTY INCLUDING FILING
FALSE REPORTS- CONVICTIONS OF
MORAL TURPITUDE AND MY QUESTION
IS. ARE BECAUSE I KNOW SO MANY
OUTSTANDING A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS OUT WHY ARE THESE
PEOPLE EVEN STILL ON THE FORCE.
IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
JURISDICTIONS- YOU KNOW THERE
ARE SO MANY OUTSTANDING MEMBERS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OUT THERE-
AND TO BE TAINTED BY THESE
FOLKS A CHANCE TO IT I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S AN ANSWER TO IT
BUT- IN READING THIS I WAS
RELEASED ON THAT ACTUALLY.
THOSE FOLKS MIGHT STILL BE
POLICE OFFICERS AND SURE OF
SOME OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
PEOPLE HIGHWAY PATROL YOU KNOW
MY FAVORITE SO. IS THERE SOME
X. FOR THAT IN THEN THE FACT
THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE A BRADY
REVELATION DOESN'T. DISTURB ME
AT ALL- I DO APPRECIATE
CONCERNED ABOUT NOTICE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND THE
ABILITY POTENTIALLY TO
CHALLENGE SOME OF THOSE.
DETERMINATIONS BUT- A- I FIND
THIS TO BE A LITTLE
DISCONCERTING THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY EVEN HAVING THAT
PARTICULAR CONVERSATION BUT
BELIEVE. I MEAN I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
A THE IMPORTANT. BUT I WONDER
CAN YOU RESPOND OR IS YUR
RESPONSE TO HOW WE COULD BE IS
STILL DEALING WITH THE- LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS WHO ARE.
IN FACT SUBJECT TO. OR HAVE HAD
THESE FINDINGS IN OFFENSES THAT
THE PERHAPS PERHAPS MORE WE
COULD THE MAN AND MIGHT.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TOTTEN WHO
DIDN'T GET THE SPEAKER HE STILL
THE LINE IF HE COULD PERHAPS.
HELP WITH THE NEXT TWENTY ON
THAT FOR MOLECULAR FOR THE
AUTHOR REACH. AND IF WANT THE
D. EIGHT ADD WE WILL ALLOW THAT
I JUST WANT TO THE D. EIGHT. TO
NOTE THAT I DID MAKE PUSH FOR.
BOTH LET ME MANAGER LET ME BE
THERE IS A AND THEN THE
ATTORNEY TODD WHOSE BETTER THAN
I IN THE AIR. PROBABLY CAN
SUPPLEMENT. THE WHAT WHAT THE
CHANNEL IS THAT IS THE- OF
MORAL TERM NOR TO DO THAT IS
WELL SO FOR. IS A- DRUNK
DRIVING. FOR FIVE YEAR AGO IS
THAT A REFLECTION OF MORAL.
DOES THAT NEED TO BE SLOW TO
THE FENCE SO YOU SOME SAY NO WE
WERE TRYING TO CA. THAT SO I
WOULDN'T ASSUME THAT EVERYONE
WHO HAS WHO CERTAINLYSHOWS UP
ON THE BRADY LIST SHOULD NO
LONGER BE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL MAYBE YES MAYBE NO
BUT BUT I DON'T THINK WE COULD
MAKE THAT. THAT THAT
ASSUMPTION- SO DISTRIBUTARY
TIGHTENED A MAN SURE IF HE
MIGHT RESPOND I WOULD
PERSONALLY DE ETAT IF YOU'RE
STILL ON THE LINE YOU MAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S YES.
FIRST OF ALL WE ARE IN MANY OF
THESE SITUATIONS DEALING WITH
PERSONNEL ACTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN BY A FRONTLINE
POLICE AGENCY AND THEN WE LEARN
ABOUT IT- VIA BRADY AND THE
PITCHES HEARING PROCESS
FOLLOWING A JUDICIAL DECISION.
SO IN SOME OF THOSE CASES- LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES TERMINATE- BUT
THE INDIVIDUAL OFFICER-
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT INVOLVES
SERIOUS ACTS OF DISHONESTY- BUT
THAT OFFICER MAY STILL WIND UP
EVEN AFTER THEIR TERMINATED-
BEING A WITNESS IN A SUBSEQUENT
CASE AND THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
DISCLOSED TO THE DEFENSE. AND
WOULD WOULD BE SUBJECTED TO THE
OFFICER WOULD BE THE FORMER
OFFICER WOULD BE SUBJECT
SUBJECTED TO EXAMINATION ON
THAT ISSUE IN OTHER CASES-
INVOLVING. ACTION THE AGENCY
MAY WANT TO TERMINATE THE
OFFICER BUT MAY BE PROHIBITED
FROM DOING SO BY THE JUDICIAL
AUTHORITY OR AN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING PROCESS AND SO THOSE
OFFICERS THAT STILL REMAIN ON
THE FORCE- WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THIS PROCESS AND WE WOULD HAVE
ACCESS. TO AT LEAST THEIR NAME
AND BADGE NUMBER SO THAT WE
COULD REQUEST A JUDICIAL
HEARING AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THAT PRIOR MISCONDUCT- WARNS
DISCLOSURE UNDER BRADY IN A IN
A SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE WOULD
WOULD MAKE THAT WHAT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO IS INSURE THAT WE
SIMPLY HAVE THE NAME AND BADGE
NUMBER. OF THE OFFICERS THAT
HAVE THESE ISSUES IN THEIR
BACKGROUND SO THAT WE CAN
APPROPRIATELY DISCLOSE
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION TO THE
DEFENSE. THANK YOU AYE MAGISTAD
THAT AMONG THE OFFENSES NACHOS.
MORAL TURPITUDE AND DISHONESTY
BUT- SUSTAIN FINDINGS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT. OF WITH A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC SO. THESE ARE SOME
SERIOUS SERIOUS- CONSIDERATIONS
AND I DO APPRECIATE. THAT
RESPONSE THANK YOU DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TODD. RIGHT ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WANT TO ASK A QUESTION
OR COMMENT CENTER BRADFORD. NOT
AS MUCH OF A QUESTION BUT A
STATEMENT AND I APPRECIATE- THE
WORK THAT CENTER ON BURKE IS
DONE IN THIS YEAR IT'S NO DOUBT
THAT. WE NEED TO HAVE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS TO BAD ACTORS
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT.
THE STATE THIS COUNTRY EVEN
WHEN YOU CATCH IT ON VIDEOTAPE
MANY OF THESE ALTER STEEL-
SCAPE- PROSECUTION OR EVEN
CHARGES SO I THINK IT'S TIME WE
I JUST DON'T THINK IT GOES FAR
ENOUGH I THINK IT STILL
PROVIDES TOO MUCH OF A LEAD WAY
TO- ALLOW OFFICERS TO BE ESCAPE
FROM THIS AND I DO BELIEVE
THERE NEEDS TO BE. A
OPPORTUNITY TO CLEAR THEIR
NAMES AS IT STATES HERE BUT I
THINK THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
SHOULD BE AFFORDED TO BLACK AND
BROWN INDIVIDUALS WHO SPEND THE
REST OF YOUR LIFE ON GANG
INJUNCTIONS AND THEY'RE NEVER
FOR THAT SAME OPPORTUNITY SO. I
THINK UNTIL WE CAN HAVE SOME
BALANCE HERE- I OR EVEN MORE
FIXED OF. WHAT C<c.cyan>. BE ON THE</c>
LIST I'M HAVE TO STAY OFF OF
FOR TODAY BUT I THINK YOU'RE.
HER EIGHT AS YOU TO CLOSE. SO
THIS ONE IS. IT WILL THIS OF A-
GREAT CAN UNDER FOR THE
COMEDIAN THAT WE HAVE THE MANY
OF THE SAME ENTITIES THAT
SUPPORTED FOR EXAMPLE THE
POLICE RECORDS BILL SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE NOW OPPOSING THIS-
BUT WE ALSO HAVE- SOME AT LEAST
ARE POLICE- UNIONS AND- THE
ALSO OPPOSING. AND YOU KNOW HOW
HOW AGAIN FOR USE THE PHRASE
APPEARS TO MANY TIMES STATE
THREAD THAT NEEDLE AND- WHAT
WHAT STRIKES ME ABOUT WHAT THE
BILL IS TRYING TO DO. IS A
NARROW CODIFICATION OF A COURT
RULING AND WHAT- I SUPPOSE WHAT
I'D- I'D APPRECIATE- THAT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT. DIDN'T LIKE THAT
COURT RULING AND SO DOESN'T
NECESSARILY- WOULD NOT LIKE US
TO CODIFY THE COURT RULING BUT
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE OFFICERS OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE WHO
ARE UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS LOG BECAUSE THEY ARE
COUNTIES OPTED TO COMPLY WITH
THE COURT RULING. NOW IT IS NOT
BEEN CONSISTENT IT IS NOT
EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE THAT-
OFFICERS ARE SUBJECT TO THIS
BECAUSE NOT ALL YOU KNOW BUT
FOR EXAMPLE THE SEATS IF I
DON'T KNOW QUITE WHY THE STATE
DIDN'T BUT CHP IS NOT. HAVING
TO COMPLY THIS WAY- BUT MANY IN
MANY COUNTIES EVERY OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT. OFFICIAL DOES SO
WHILE I APPRECIATE THAT MANY OF
OUR- ADVOCATES WOULD WOULD AS
CENTER BRADFORD DESCRIBED WANT
US TO. NOT MOVE TO CODIFY THIS
WITHOUT BEING MORE EXPANSIVE I
GUESS WHERE I FELL IS THAT.
THIS I A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION NOW OF COURSE THERE
IS ALWAYS THE CONCERN THAT IF
WE TAKETHIS STEP THEN. IT WILL
BE A EITHER WILL MAKE IT VERY
VERY DIFFICULT OR IMPOSSIBLE TO
GO FURTHER NOW OF COURSE FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT SINCE
PERSPECTIVE ARE TAKING EVEN
THIS STEP IS A STEP TOO FAR.
AND I GUESS I AM COMFORTABLE
WITH CODIFYING. THE COURT
DECISION IN THE NEAR A WAY THAT
IT'S BEEN CONSTRUCTED I
CERTAINLY DO- AND WOULD
ENTERTAIN A BILL THAT WENT
FURTHER. BUT I GUESS I DON'T
OPPOSE TAKING THE POSITIVE STEP
IN THE DIRECTION SO- THAT IS
WHY I HAVE RECOMMENDED THAT IS
WHY I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL IS CONSTRUCTED. AND
APPRECIATING THAT FEAR AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE TESTIMONY THERE
WILL BE MANY- THERE WILL BE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO NOT- LIKE
THAT DECISION IN THERE WILL BE
ADVOCATES WHO OR ADVOCATES- LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ALSO ADVOCATES
BUT RATHER. ADVOCATE TO WANT
MORE DISCLOSURE WHO WOULD NOT
BE HAPPY WITH THAT BUT I THINK
SOME ACTION TO MAKE IT A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD ACROSS THE STATE
THAT SO THAT ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE.
FUNCTIONING UNDER THE COURT
RULING IS AT IMPROVEMENT OVER
WHAT WE HAVE NOW. LET'S SEE IF
THERE IS A MOTION OR NOT. SO
RIGHT WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS
THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTER.
SENATOR UMBERG YOU CAN CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- IN
MEMBERS LET ME FIRST ADDRESS OF
THE BRADFORDS BUT ONE OF HIS
ISSUES SPENT AND THEN SOME OF
THE OTHER CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED- TAKING THIS BILL FROM
THE DEFENDANT'S PERSPECTIVE.
WORST CASE SCENARIO IS WHERE
THERE'S A ON OFFICER WHO IS A
KEY WITNESS WHO HAS SOMETHING
IN HIS OR HER BACKGROUND SO FOR
EXAMPLE LET'S SAY A SUSTAIN
FINDING OF FILING A FALSE
POLICE REPORT. THE DEFENDANT
AND HIS LAWYER HER LAWYER
SHOULD SHOULD KNOW ABOUT THAT
SO THAT THEY CAN EXAMINE THE
OFFICE OF SADLY THERE ARE SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THAT IS NOT
BEING REVEALED TODAY SO IF YOU
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT AND IT
CAN'T BE. JUST THEN YOU MAY
HAVE AN UNFAIR RESULTS SO WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS BY THE
WAY THIS IS THIS IS A FLOOR NOT
A CEILING COULD DO MORE. IT'S A
SIMPLE A SORT OF BASE STANDARD.
SO FROM THE- YOU WANT
INFORMATION. AND YOU WANT
POLICE ENTITIES HAVE TO BE ABLE.-A REVEAL THOSE OFFICERS WHO MAY
HAVE IS. SUCH AS THAT IN THEIR
FILE. FROM THE POLICE OFFICERS
PERSPECTIVE. IT IS TRUE AND
I'VE HEARD MANY STORIES OF
POLICE OFFICERS THAT ARE PUT ON
THE BRADY LIST THAT PERHAPS IT
SHOULD BE ON THE BRINK LIST.
BUT MANY PLACES IN THE STATE
ARE NOT LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
ALAMEDA CEMETERY VENTURA COUNTY
THEY DON'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANY REVIEW. THEY DON'T HAVE
AN OTHER THAN GOING TO COURT IN
AND FILING A WRIT WHICH IS BOTH
EXPENSIVE AND VERY VERY
DIFFICULT SO THEY CAN'T THEY
THEY CAN'T GET OFF THE LIST.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME EVER
THIS IS DELICIOUS A FLOOR.
OTHER DISTRICT ATTORNEY CAN
PROVIDE EVEN MORE AND YOU CAN
GO. ONE FOUR. THE LEAST THIS OF.
EVER LAW AND- ON AND I. TO HAVE.
SORT OF REVIEW IN THE STATE.
THEN FROM THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S PERSPECTIVE. THEY
WANT TO DO THEY WANT TO DO
JUSTICE AND SO THEY WANT TO
REVEAL IF THIS IS EXCULPATORY
MITIGATING INFORMATION THEY
WANT TO REVEAL THAT. FOR
SEVERAL REASONS ONE TO DO
JUSTICE BUT ALSO IS THIS
BECOMES AVAILABLE THIS COMES TO
LIGHTLATER ON. THAT CONVICTION
COULD BE REVERSED AND SO THAT
DOESN'T DO ANY GOOD FOR ANYBODY
ANYWAY SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
TRIES TO DO ADMITTEDLY THERE'S
STILL THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT ADMITTEDLY WE'D LIKE
TO HAVE A MORE DEFINED LIST OF
WHAT IS MORAL TURPITUDE.
WORKING HARD WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING HARD TO TRY TO GET
THESE THINGS RESOLVED BUT- BUT-
BUT THIS IS A TOUGH ISSUE AND
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP WORKING AT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR URGED
BIBLE. ALL RIGHT- SEEING NO
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE
HAVE A- MOTION. AND WE WILL DO
A ROLL CALL. IN THIS IS. GO
AHEAD STATE THE MOTION SEARCH
SB TWELVE TWENTY DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BY IN OUR AYE
MORLOCK MORE LIKE I BROUGH. GEN
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL. MORRELL.
WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER ONLINE.
FOUR ZERO. YOUR THE BILL AS
FOUR ZERO IT IS OUT. RIGHT THE
MOVIE- YEAH WE HAVE CONSENT
CALENDAR HOT THANK YOU CENTER
MOORLACH FOR THAT MOTION- WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX
IS THE ONLY BILL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SKINNER ALL RIGHT IN
OUR AYE MOORLACH MORE LIKE AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL. IT'S A
AYE AYE MORALE. HI BROWN AYE
WIENER. ALL RIGHT WIENER AYE
SEVEN ZERO OKAY AND- WE- JUST
BY NOR DISSIDENT RECORD JUST
BUDGET FOR THE RECORD WE DID
GRANT RICAN FOR SB EIGHT FIFTY
THREE AND OTHERWISE. SB ELEVEN
I SIX SB FOR N. SB. TWELVE TO
TWELVE SEVENTY WERE ALL THROUGH
IN OR OUT AND WITH THAT. WE
WILL. MY FIST IS THE GAVEL WE
WILL ADJOURN. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU ALL PRECIADO. TWENTY
Q. STAFF THE THESE- HEARINGS
ARE NOT EASY TO CONSTRUCT
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
EFFORT THAT HAS BEEN MADE TO
ALLOW US TO FUNCTION WITH AS
MUCH DELIBERATION AND PUBLIC
INPUT AND APPRECIATE IT NO THAT
IT'S DIFFICULT AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.